Five four,
three,
two,
one
funk.
Does that sound that everybody knows?
Like if you play that sound,
people know that's an Arrow,
right?
Yup.
But it may be throwing knife,
but you known as an arrow.
Dang.
Right.
We do.
Dang right.
That's it.
That's an Iowa boy right there.
That's the midwest coming out here.
Sometimes I hear you on your podcast and
I'm like,
man,
he is so midwest.
It's hilarious.
Sorry about that.
That don't apologize.
It's awesome.
I'm actually more of a half breed.
I'm a little bit of south,
right?
Yeah.
I was a redneck for awhile and then then
became a Yankee.
My,
the people up north don't give a it.
They don't give a shit what people think
north or South.
But this,
the people from the south,
my family,
they're like,
you're part Yankee now.
Yeah.
Not Weird.
It's a little weird.
They lost.
That's why they lost the war thing.
Can you imagine?
I mean,
we are,
we're several generations removed.
But imagine growing up in like the late
18 hundreds when it just happened and
you're dealing with Yankees Samos,
my mom murders,
right.
People Killed Northerners and
northerners killed southerners.
And it must have been a lot of that.
It was ruthless,
I'm sure.
Oh,
how the fuck did that happen?
That is a crazy time you think about
the,
the history of this country that just
200 years ago we were in,
you know,
less.
We're in the middle of a bitter war from
the,
the north versus the south Americans
fighting Americans to the death,
big fields full of dead people.
Um,
my dad was at one of the fields,
I forget which field it was.
Um,
but uh,
he said,
you know,
it's one of those memorial places in the
south.
And he said the feelings Berg or
something.
Yeah.
Want it was Gettysburg and he sent you
feel it.
He's like,
you feel sadness then.
Yeah.
So I get sound.
I know it sounds crazy.
And he was saying,
I don't even believe in that stuff,
but you feel it.
Like you're there and you're like,
okay.
Oh yeah.
We've been in a few memorials.
Um,
a few memorials and a few big,
you know,
like,
especially like military cemeteries.
Oh,
you just,
uh,
you know another one.
I felt it like exactly what you're
saying.
Um,
I went to,
um,
a historic part of custer where they
lost the battle and I walked the whole
hill and everything.
You can feel it there.
Wow.
What is that?
Do you think there's like memory in
places?
Hell yeah.
There is.
Yeah.
It probably is.
Right.
I think there is probably an instinctive
reason why people don't want to live in
a house where someone was murdered.
Yeah.
I don't want to live there.
I could you like,
um,
there's a house that Jon Benet Ramsey
was killed in,
in Colorado.
They can't sell that fucking house.
Dude.
I live there.
Mm.
Nine years ago,
eight years ago,
somewhere on with them nine years
ago and they were selling it then they
still can't sell it.
It's a beautiful house.
It's in a really nice neighborhood.
Can't sell it.
They have changed the name of the
street.
They changed the name of the street.
Still can't sell it.
I'm not kidding.
They just can't sell it.
It has it.
Does it have like historical everybody's
terrible sightings and stuff or was it
just the killing?
Just the killing and the hold.
The darkness all behind it.
I mean that was one.
It was just was,
it wasn't just a little girl died,
but there's all this darkness.
She was sexually active.
There was something going like someone
was probably molesting her,
someone in the family or someone else
who knows.
They think someone in the family might
have killed her.
They don't know who it was.
It's never been solved.
No one's ever been tried.
It's a dark.
Yeah,
I'm not moving there.
Fuck that.
They can keep that,
keep that house.
I think they should level that thing to
the ground and maybe even do something
with the ground underneath it.
Scoop all that shit out.
Put some new dirt and I'm not kidding.
I'm not kidding.
Like that might be the only way you're
going to throw that Mojo on though.
You've got to put that term.
You got to put that dirt somewhere.
Yeah,
he's worthy of taking it.
Right.
Where would you put that dirt?
You have to exercise it.
You'd have to build like the most
awesome park for kids.
Like you'd have to turn that house into
something positive.
I don't want to do anything for kids.
They're for sure that would be bad
taste,
but you could always take that big scoop
and kind of put it in a freak party
desert or something where people that
like ghosts and crap can go out there
and play in it or camp on it or what he
likes little kid ghosts you want like
some old man goes can tell you secrets.
Have you ever seen it?
You think you've ever seen?
He goes,
no,
I do not.
Have you ever experienced something that
was like super creepy that you know
what?
A couple of my friends at the comedy
store have claimed to have seen ghosts
and claim to have seen things and I with
many of my friends that work there and
comics and stuff,
we've gone upstairs to the belly room in
the dark,
just freaked ourselves out and went and
ran out of there.
Stoned out of her mind.
I feel it.
We got to go.
Well,
are you going into the main room at
night?
You know,
like,
give me a hug.
Hold me.
Ah,
I'm scared.
It's,
it's a weird place,
man.
People for sure been murdered there.
It was a bugsy Siegel's nightclub in the
19.
What was it,
the thirties or forties or some shit.
It was Ciro's nightclub.
Yeah,
there's definitely some Mojo there,
cal.
Yeah,
for sure.
How do we get going down the pattern of
death?
I mean,
all I do was write a werewolf and
pictures.
Awesome.
Go to my instagram.
John Dudley is riding the Werewolf.
We were trying to figure out,
well,
the wearables,
um,
Patrick McGee made that Werewolf and it
comes in to pate pieces.
You slide it out and ball.
Patrick Biggie has a new movie out.
I should pump his new movie out.
If you're into,
there it is.
See it.
Fuck you.
Fix your bed.
Oh my God.
It's hilarious.
It's got 5,000 likes already.
I put it up two minutes ago.
That's such an awesome picture.
I know.
Pat Mcgee,
the guy who made that,
uh,
just made a movie,
a big foot movie.
It's called a primal scream,
I think.
Isn't that what it's called?
It just came out.
Is it a legit one or like a horror
movie?
Oh yeah.
Put your monster.
Okay.
Kellen people.
I watched that Jack and people in the
woods.
I watch that.
Yeah.
It got good reviews.
I hope it's good.
I love me a good big foot movie and
there's not a whole lot of them.
I think we would've saw bigfoot a long
time ago.
There's,
yeah,
for sure.
I think,
but,
but um,
what would you do if you actually ran
across one double lung,
which you take the,
take the penalty double on proven point.
No,
I would hope I'd have my camera on me,
but then people would call me a fucking
liar.
That would be a bummer.
If you really saw big foot,
you're like,
God damn it.
He's real.
Never one's gonna think I'm crazy
because everybody that I know that
believes in big foot,
I'm always looking.
All right.
Everybody thinks they chart.
Even if you've got a picture,
no one,
no one's going to believe.
Yeah.
Then you're going to meet all the good
faith that you've built up by being
honest all these years,
people fuck that guy.
He's full of Shit.
He faked a bigfoot sighting man.
Yeah,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't shoot it.
Definitely not.
But I think if it was real,
I really do believe that if it was real,
this is the,
uh,
the trailer for Omar C and Pat Mcgee did
this with a all special effects like
suits and shit and actual makeup and
prosthetics and all the stuff that they
used in the old movies.
Like he doesn't believe in that CGI
shit.
And I think he's got a point at CGI
It's just too,
it takes away.
It does.
I mean,
you look back at some of the movies that
scared,
you know,
scared the hell out of you when you're a
kid and you watch them down and you're
like,
what the man did?
They,
it just seems so much more real.
But if you watch something to where you
know it's fake,
it's almost,
can't picture the fact that it's flesh
and blood.
Right.
And you need,
you don't feel it.
Like there's some of those transformer
type movies.
They're smashing buildings and like,
I know this isn't happening.
Just you don't feel it.
It doesn't feel like a real explosion.
It doesn't feel like a real robot.
Just feels like horseshit.
Yeah,
but the Dyno bots pretty.
They're pretty dope.
What's the Dyno Bot?
It's a dinosaur version.
Is that one of the transformers and your
years?
Well,
schooled
robots and transformers were the bomb
man when I was a kid.
That and a cabbage patch kids.
So it wasn't a crazy that that became,
that transformers became huge hit
movies.
It was a dumb toy,
right?
Yup.
Was it originally a toy?
Yeah.
Transformers.
They were cool and shouldn't say dumb
toy.
If anyone's a collector,
they're freaking out.
Right.
Dumb to me.
How about that?
Yeah,
go bots and transformers.
They were,
I mean,
before that you had,
you know,
army men Musselman.
You remember those?
Those little pink muscle
man?
They were all freaking jacked.
You know what I remember?
I remember stretch Armstrong.
Yeah,
home part.
Okay.
Yeah.
They never made a movie out of him,
did they?
My boy.
What's funny is they didn't have,
they did have some of that stuff there.
They are a little muscle.
Then there's something that looks really
good about that.
They're all pink girl pink and those
were pretty cool.
Just on a,
just a roundabout gas.
How many dudes have stuffed those up
their house?
Hundreds or thousands.
I'd say thousands.
Thousands,
right.
Thousands of people.
I've had those in there as we're going
down that road already.
Why not?
If you just,
if we could pull out like a pullback,
you think of a teenage mutant Ninja
Turtles,
right?
Did not start off as a,
was that a comic book?
It was a comic.
That was a comic book.
Yeah.
It wasn't a toy first.
That's my boy.
He really got into,
I don't know what it was,
but he had this Peter Pan doll and I
think because he didn't have a brother
or sister,
he would beat the shit out of this Peter
Pan doll and he wouldn't do it when
everyone was there.
But you know,
you as adults,
she of,
you know,
you ended up coming around the corner to
see if they're okay or whatever.
Maybe.
We went downstairs for a while and I
come up there and I mean he's just got
his back to the door.
Just fricking power drop in Peter Pan
just kicking this thing in the face
punched in it.
I mean Sharon and I just laugh about it
or like he doesn't do it with anyone
else who for whatever reason Peter Pan
is just his little brother and he just
kicks the shit out of that sucker.
Peter Pan's his bitch.
What about Robin Hood?
There was a robin hood toys ever did
ever kids ever get a robin hood toy that
we need a disney movie,
so I'm sure it got around now.
But that was because of the story,
right?
Robin had the Disney movie.
It was all because of the original rob.
You story physical like action figures.
Were they popular?
I don't think so.
Yeah,
No.
Maybe when that Kevin Costner movie came
out,
they sold a few,
but I bet they didn't.
I'd say a lot.
Maybe a few.
I forgot that was a movie.
How bad was Kevin Costner's forum and
that movie was it?
Okay.
Um,
did you watch it and go,
Whoa,
I gotta go.
It's like when I,
when I see bad karate movies,
I'm like,
get the fuck right there.
I Dunno.
L Elvis doing karate.
I watched that.
I sent you a text.
I'm like,
I watched that so long.
Kevin Costner and Christian Slater to
checkout that feather the feathering on
the back of his hair.
Yeah.
It was members from the duck feather was
like kind of kind of the style.
Yeah.
The feathering.
The hearing somehow or another,
he got his hair feathered wise in the
fucking forest.
Nottingham was perfect haircut.
He's got a soup.
Look at that.
Come on man.
It's got a super cuts right down the
street.
The fuck did you get that hair cut son?
You that haircut I got the other day.
Cost cutters.
Look how they made arrowheads.
Is that real?
Is that really how they did it?
Yeah.
It looks like he's pouring a full metal
one.
Wow.
That's dope.
Yeah.
They would melt it down and pour it in a
cast thing out like a rocky mountain cut
throat or something.
I'll look at his,
showing them,
making the arrows in the bows and shit.
Yep.
Wow.
It's right there.
He goes,
drive home in it.
How did they possibly know?
Did they use scales to figure out how
much the arrows weighed back then it was
even a scallop.
No fucking guy on the right.
It's killing me.
That's about how everyone would shoot
with that equipment.
Nowadays.
Morgan Freeman was asthma blood.
Why in the fuck beyond the wormhole?
This is hilarious.
This is so dumb.
I'm a Kevin Costner Fan.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not a hater,
but damn Kevin costs has been in some
stinkers.
Oh,
now they're getting better.
Look.
Oh yeah,
they learned Little Robin had coaching.
It wasn't bad.
Good,
bad.
Oh,
just split another one.
Wow.
Look at his skills.
See,
people don't understand.
Splitting an Arrow is fucking stupid.
It's costly.
It's not wise.
Well,
at least there was no cgi in this for
sure.
I mean,
I licked the feather before you're
fired.
Is he trying to curve it around it.
I don't know what he's doing.
Why is he looking at,
he's going to cut the string.
Let me this.
They got all the dramas killing me.
Sincerely is saying I wasn't sure if it
was going to hit.
The drama is killing me.
That's a slow ass heroine,
right?
Yeah.
How much,
I mean seconds.
I don't know if you shot that and access
dear thanks.
Just Steve would be like be on the other
island.
I've never seen anything like those
things.
Um,
John and I hunted axis deer in Hawaii
where they were brought over.
I was reading as a like a gift to the
king in the 18 hundreds hosted that
today actually.
Yeah,
that's probably where I was reading it.
I'm pretty sure I knew it already,
but I think of it,
that's exactly where I was reading it.
But they,
I've never seen anything move as fast as
those things.
Like you could shoot at one that's 40
yards away and by the time the Arrow
gets there,
it's nowhere near it.
It's like Chung.
Yeah.
You need to load those fast twitch
muscles in a UFC fighter of today.
Just be concussion city.
It'd be crazy.
I've never just,
I've never seen an animal react to
something so quick,
but it makes sense that they evolved
around Tigers,
tigers and leopards.
Fucking shit.
Roll the dice.
Imagine being tiger and Leopard
preferred food.
And that's the other thing about axis
deer.
They are delicious.
Yup.
Yeah.
Like one of the most delicious animals
on the planet.
And obviously tigers must know this.
Oh I bet they have to know it.
Yeah.
I mean there has to be a correlation
between something that's extra fast and
extra delicious.
I really think there is.
Well does that make sense?
Not really.
Right?
Because like I dunno what to eat a
hummingbird probably tastes like shit.
I think a lot of it's their diet and how
much they're actually having to move
too.
Yeah.
Cause I think things that are running a
lot like full speed,
it seems like the meat maybe isn't as
tinder,
but it's hard to say.
That's true.
Well.
Um,
what I've found is that Chad ward
method,
the your your friend whiskey bent
barbecue,
he's changed the way I cook meat.
Um,
I do that here now and I use a meat
thermometer.
Always.
The only time I don't is when I um,
I will saute backstraps slices or steak
slices in a frying pan,
like a cast iron grill.
I'll put some butter and some garlic
salt and some cracked pepper and I'll
just cook them pretty quick on a really
hot skillet.
I like cooking like that too.
Yeah.
But when I cook like a roast or
something like that or a thick piece of
meat,
I always use Chad's method.
Yup.
It's a way to go get it,
get the internal temperature.
I get it to around one 20 and then I
take it out and just sear the outside
and the frying pan and let it sit for 10
minutes.
And Oh,
one thing that a lot of people don't
realize too,
um,
when it comes to cooking,
a really good roast or a steak or
anything is I love having those soft
Yeti bags or the smaller cooler.
And I'll take the stuff and actually you
know,
kind of wrap it up just slightly and
foiler but your paper and then put it in
the cooler and let it actually stage in
there and you know,
and just stage in that moisture while
I'm doing my vegetables cause it takes
about 20 minutes to do vegetables and
then take it out right at the very end
to do that reverse year.
Normally when I put it in there,
it gives me time to get,
you know,
a cast iron pan hot enough with the
butter to do reverse sear.
So it's like really good for timing and
it,
it really helps break down that that
protein a little bit and it just makes
it that much more tender.
That's interesting because I was doing
that for a while but I was doing it
after I did the seer.
I was,
I was taking it right from the grill and
then I was searing it.
Like I'd have the Pan Ready,
I'd see her right off the grill and then
I'd wrap it in foil and put it into yet.
But then you don't get kind of that
crispness of this year,
which he like were at,
because it stays moist until you're
saying,
yeah,
yeah.
Stage at first start your vege and then
like you know,
probably two minutes before you feel
like you're going to pull your
vegetables off.
Just get that butter going in that cast
iron pan and then do your reverse here.
You know you can do one side and then as
soon as you flip it,
pull your veggies off the grill and
you're literally,
you can go right back to the,
you know that one side,
your reverse sear and take it off and
you're serving hot.
Everything's done well.
That's one thing that I really give
credit to.
Steve Rinella.
Steve Rinella really got me interested
in wild game cooking.
And then Hank Shaw,
who he had on his TV show who's a
brilliant chef and he's gay,
he's got a couple of books out.
One of them is buck,
Buck Moose I think,
and then he's got another one duck moose
or something.
So I had it sitting here for a while til
we moved everything off.
This stable,
it's table gets so cluttered.
I'm always trying to put,
everyone has always given me books and
also there was just sitting here,
just got one.
They're always just stacking up and I've
been meaning to give you this book.
Moose recipes and techniques for cooking
deer,
elk,
and Moose by Hank Shaw.
It's awesome.
It's really good.
I'd be no,
his book's really good too.
He's got two of them.
Hunting and cooking wild game.
I feel I'm so inferior to those guys
when it comes to cooking.
Oh yeah.
But I almost liked the fact that that
people really like my cooking or at
least the pictures and what I make,
people are really into it because if
they knew that my knowledge of cooking
wild game is so limited,
it's,
it should be hope for anybody to be able
to cook that easy.
Because I'm not those guys.
I mean,
I think if,
you know,
I would love to do that,
but I'm as simple as it gets when it
comes to to grill and stuff.
Yeah.
But I'm telling you there's an art to
that simplicity.
Like just you describing your method
for,
you know,
like letting it stage and then searing
it and what we learned from Chad when we
cook that wild pig.
Yup.
That was amazing.
That was so good.
And I think there's,
there's something amazing in that
simplicity because a lot of people fuck
that simplicity up.
Like that simplicity is a real common
one to screw up.
People just overdo it or overcook it or
something goes wrong.
But um,
Rinella really turned me on to all the
various really fascinating dishes and he
had several episodes of his TV show
mediator that are just dedicated to
cooking.
And I don't,
there's not a lot of hunting shows that
ever have that.
It's always just about hunting and then
the shot of the animal getting shot and
then everybody's smiling and high five
and that's it.
Roll credits when it's pretty much,
yeah,
60 70% of all those hunting shows and
his really stands out because it's like,
hey,
this guy's a real chef.
I mean,
it's an amateur chef,
but he's a real chef.
He knows a lot about cooking and he
makes these delicious meals and they're
intricate.
It like,
it makes us really cool.
Elk Meat Loaf,
it was really good.
I've never done anything with Steve.
We've,
we've passed,
we've actually been within the same
group of friends talking at times,
but we've never actually done something
where we had to have a communication
just the two of us.
But um,
yeah,
he's a fascinating dude.
Very,
very smart guy.
I would love to actually,
I talked with a remi and uh,
I told Remy,
I said I would love to do,
um,
just a weekend getaway where we just go
back country and all you teach,
you know,
just Kinda,
I want to just follow remy and see some
of his,
you know,
just as natural,
like camping and survival type skills
and then actually do an on the mounting
coaching thing with Remi.
We were talking about doing a show where
I literally retrain his way of shooting
while he's retraining my way of back
country hunting.
And literally he's doing his element.
I'm doing mine and we're able to to just
do it in the middle of nowhere.
That sounds cool.
Yeah,
it'd be pretty fun.
Well,
I'm really fascinated by what remi does
and uh,
Tim Barnett and a bunch of those guys
that have,
um,
really taken up solo,
back hunt,
back country hunting where they backpack
in and they'll go in 20 miles with a
backpack.
I mean,
obviously,
uh,
my favorite stories,
Adam Green tree,
that fucking crazy bastard.
Our good friend Adam went all the way
deep into the mountains of Colorado and
then again he went,
came out for a bit and went to Idaho,
right?
Yep.
And that's when he had all the Grizzly
and counters,
but 28 days just living out of a
backpack and putting his camp on its
back most of the nights and just
carrying it around and just living
literally off your back.
And there's an art to that and remmy
doesn't just do that,
but he also solo films,
everything,
which is incredible.
Well that's,
well,
I don't solo back country hunt that I
definitely have really.
Most of my tv show experience has all
been from cell filming.
I mean,
I've been doing it 20 something years.
A lot of what you saw for me,
it was all self filmed,
which a lot of people don't appreciate
how tough that really is until,
yeah.
I mean it is hard.
It's hard enough to,
uh,
to hunt and be successful.
But to film it is like a whole
Ooh,
new level.
Yeah.
Just to bring the cameras around with
you.
And like with Remi,
like if we're watching a show solo
hunter or timber nat,
the other guy that's on each other
always like holding the tripod,
running up the hill while they're also
holding a bow and setting it up and
putting the camera in place and then
trying to draw back and trying to get
the,
and move the camera because the deer's
move in like Gopros helped a lot.
I'm just fascinated by the people that
choose to go deep into the woods and
live by themselves and do it for long,
long periods of time because it's,
um,
it's,
it's a very interesting and solitary
pursuit.
Like when you're out there,
there's no TV,
there's no phones,
there's just you,
you only,
and a backpack and a little tent,
maybe a baby.
You're sleeping under the stars and then
you get up in the morning and do it all
over again.
And some of these guys do it for like
20,
30 days at a time.
It's crazy.
It's hard for me to,
uh,
I don't actually like to post.
I don't even if I'm out camping on a
hunt,
I actually don't post when I'm doing
that just because of those guys.
Out of respect for those guys,
it's who really,
really,
I mean,
honestly,
I,
I understand what they're doing and I
don't,
you know,
it's no different than,
there's,
there's people that post photos shooting
archery when,
when,
when I look back and see how long
they've really done it.
And you know,
they build up a persona,
but there's also guys,
there's guys that have done it twice as
long as me,
but there's guys like me that have done,
you know,
possibly millions of arrows.
Um,
so it's,
it's hard to,
to see people like make pretend to be
that.
And I feel like I'm that guy.
If I,
if I post a picture of,
of me out in the back country in a Bibi,
it's not the same as seeing Adam posts a
picture and a bivy or remy or Rinella.
We should explain a Bibi that people
don't know what it is.
It's like a combination tent.
Sleeping bag.
Yup.
Yeah.
I mean it's like literally you can get,
yeah,
you can stuff it in your bag,
go out and you're more or less a
hunting.
Just lay it on the ground,
sleeping on the ground.
You got some little bit of cover.
Sometimes people bring pads,
sometimes the hard,
hard hardcore dudes don't even bring
pads.
There you go.
That guy is shooting Alan Yang.
That's how I wake up.
Wake up and Oh,
I hear an elk wake and bake.
Right.
Breakfast is served.
Yeah.
Well that's crazy.
He's all got Cammo on the Bibi too.
Can you appreciate that though?
Yeah,
I feel that way.
It's not just in the hunting world.
It's like that with a lot of things.
Um,
but you know why?
If I have a truck,
I have trouble posting pictures working
out.
I know what you mean.
Yeah.
Like I'll,
I make sure I make sure people that are
following me and trying to maybe be
motivated by what my daily routine is.
I like them to see that I'm going and
things like that.
But to actually post that I'm doing it
because I do it to stay healthy.
It's not my life.
Right.
And archery is my life.
So that's why sometimes it gets hard for
me when people are pretending to do that
or,
you know,
and I guess I don't have a problem with
people doing it,
but I don't want him to do it.
But yeah,
I don't want to be enthusiastic about
it,
but I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
I just,
I'm trying to show respect for the
people that are literally putting in the
grind for those specific things.
The same as what I have done with my
life or archery.
That's all I'm saying.
I know.
Exactly,
Sam.
It's like,
uh,
I dunno.
I have a different attitude about that
with standup comedy.
Um,
cause I really,
really like when new people get into
standup comedy and it's,
that's contrary to like how a lot of
professionals feel.
Like I was talking to a friend of mine
the other day,
she's very funny and she was telling me
that her uncle was a thinking about
getting into comedy and she was like,
oh well,
Oh God,
no.
You know.
But when people ask me like,
hey man,
I'm thinking about doing comedy,
I'm like,
you could do it.
Anybody can do it.
Just figure it out.
It's just like everything else.
It's like Jujitsu or
mm.
Martial arts like fit,
fill in the blank.
It's anything else.
It's like music.
You learn the chords.
You figured out how to play,
you can do it.
You might not be able to do it,
but that might be on you.
I mean like whether or not,
I think if you're a rational person,
he thinks and you like comedy and people
laugh at you.
Like you say funny shit.
Sometimes you can be a stand up,
will you?
Will you do it?
I don't know.
People think it's a lot easier than it
is.
They don't really know.
They don't see,
um,
there's no way you could.
There's no,
I mean you think about all the hours,
all the time,
all the different sets.
But I like it when people get into it.
So if some new kid has only been doing
comedy for three weeks,
throws a bunch of pictures on his
instagram page about going to an open
mic,
died,
I'm happy.
Like go get it kid.
Well,
I mean especially when it comes to art
form,
there's kind of a line there.
Cause when it comes to competition,
I'm very,
very
active in getting people involved with
trying to compete because I always felt
like even as a coach,
when I helped people that were maybe not
up to the rank that I was,
I felt like once I felt the pressure of
them pushing on my heels,
it always elevated my game for sure.
And I've got friends that,
I've got friends that are within
different fields that I'm in.
And they actually have came to me and
said,
hey,
we want to show you exactly how we're
doing this.
Um,
and in a way I'm a competitor because
I'm in the outdoor business,
but there's been a few times where some
of my friends have said,
the reason we're telling you exactly how
we do it is because we know that you're
going to do it different,
but maybe a little bit better.
And some of them have said,
we're stale right now.
We know we're stale,
we need to push and we need someone to
like push past us.
So that will our competitive drive
we'll,
we'll push through.
Well you know what,
in the outdoor business,
but I'm going to steal a page from my
friend Sturgis book.
Not a real book,
but we said the other day,
he's like,
he goes,
I'm not really in the music business.
I'm in the sturgill Simpson business.
And I was like,
damn,
that's right.
He's right because I'm not in show
business.
Yup.
I'm in the Joe Rogan business.
100% like,
I mean I'm in show business in terms of
like,
I guess I work for the UFC,
that's show business.
I,
I show up at the comedy store that's
show business.
But that's where,
that's my gym.
Yeah.
That's where I'm practicing to be in the
Joe Rogan business.
And you're in the John Dudley business,
you know,
I mean what I was saying before,
I wanted to let you continue your
thought,
but what I wanted to say was the you
feel that way because you're a legit
guy.
Cause like what you've done,
like a lot of people don't realize
there's a lot of people in the archery
world and there's a lot of people in the
bow hunting world to talk about bow
hunting and they were really into our
tree.
But your background as a competitive
archer is just insane.
I mean you really,
like,
most people don't even know,
like you really did it all over the
world.
I mean you compete internationally,
you flew millions of miles.
I mean that you did the whole deal and
it,
it's something that you,
because of the fact that you know,
you put so much effort and so much hard
work into it and you're solidified as
100% legit,
you're very sensitive to things that
you're not legit in.
So that's why you're a very authentic
person.
Like when you're thinking about like all
the running,
like when I post pictures of running,
I often think like,
yeah,
I'm running but I don't even have like a
real job.
Cam hanes is out there,
rode 25 miles a day,
that fucking crazy ass and he's one of
my best friends.
It's like I can't really,
I can't really think that I'm really
run.
I mean I know I'm doing it,
but it's bitch ass running.
I didn't want to use that example,
but to do an example,
that is the perfect example because
yeah,
I don't post pictures of me.
Yesterday I actually did arm day.
I'm not like arm day all the time,
but yesterday was,
let me have some of that Alpha brain.
Yesterday was a legitimate arm day and I
thought
Cam's already posts arm day and he does
it every day.
So yeah,
I don't know.
I know he doesn't get tendinitis.
No,
cause I'm going,
he's down this dude,
I don't know.
Why doesn't he have a tendonitis in his
legs?
That's true.
Runs it.
He's we,
you and I talked about,
I've shot a right handed Bo my entire,
well I shouldn't say my entire life when
I hurt my shoulder,
I had to shoot a left hand,
a bow.
But um,
for the most part I've shot a right
handed boat my whole life.
So my,
my left,
I mean my left Pec is bigger than my,
than my right.
My left jelled.
Yeah,
my left tricep.
And then on my right side,
my right trap,
the way my whole right side sits in my
bicep or also from pulling a boat my
entire life.
And you and I talked about,
you know,
if you really wanted to balance yourself
and stay symmetrical,
you almost need to shoot lefthanded as
much as you shoot right hand.
Yeah.
Well that's the key with martial arts.
But in a way,
I mean that is what Cam's doing.
He's running right?
It's all lower body.
And then he's literally lifting upper
body every day,
which is a balance.
I mean,
people are going to,
people are definitely going to say,
well you can't train up her body every
day,
but he trains lower body every day.
So is it like,
I've thought that many times
low weight,
high reps,
not always so low either.
By the way.
That kind of strong as fuck.
Like you'd be kind of stunned and how
strong he is.
Like he came over here and uh,
he picked up my hundred and 25 pound
dumbbells and he was doing presses.
So he's pressing to 50 with dumbbells,
you know,
and he's,
it mean
is it,
he's a crazy guy.
Like I don't know anybody like him.
So like he's doing,
he's doing low weight,
high rep running.
He's doing that.
But I'm saying he also lifts to 50 with
dumbbells and he only weighs like 175
pounds.
I mean,
it's pretty crazy shit.
He's a felon at one 75 and I'm two 25.
He's a tank.
He's a madman.
Like I've met a lot of people that have
a lot of drive but he has a very unusual
drive.
It's very,
it's real weird.
Have you ever done the math on I'm,
sometimes
you shoot most of the time you shoot a
hundred arrows but I know there's been
times where you and I have shot where
you've shot where I know I've shot over
a hundred arrows and you've shot double
that because normally when I'm about
saying I have feel like I had a good
practice.
You're like yeah man,
I feel really warmed up right now.
You know where that comes from.
It comes from playing pool when I and
when you play pool,
this is,
this is real high level competitive pool
and I was never high level but um,
when I got to be as good as I got,
I was always a what you would call a b
player.
It takes a lot to become a b player.
But I was always a b player and there's
a,
is an a player,
an a player like borders pro and then
there's pro,
which is like stratospheric,
like you know Earl stricklin effort and
ray is best of the best top of the food
chain.
This is different level,
but when you play pool,
as you get better and better,
one of the things that,
uh,
that you get,
you develop like this feel and the feel
really kicks in with me about eight
hours in.
So I would,
I would be practicing,
I'm not joking,
eight hours and I had a full on
sickness.
Go ahead and pull that.
I know you're trying to do it off the
mic.
How addictive of these goddamn on it.
Protein bites.
Holy Shit.
I want stock in these right there.
It's on these fricking to say good.
I hate for those this morning.
And I told myself I was willing to eat
one.
I was just doing some shit around the
house before I made breakfast and my
fasted a window was up and so I was
like,
I can eat now.
It's like I just have one of these
things.
I ate one.
I'm like I'm definitely having to,
and then I ate too cause there's two in
a package and I said fuck that.
I'm hoping in another package I ate four
of them.
So I,
what is it,
seven grams each.
So there's 28 grams of protein.
I ate inside of five minutes.
These are so good.
Prepare from I the other day I said for
anyone out there don't do it.
Cause if you do it,
whatever these,
whatever these are,
you're going to go from like this,
the new on it.
These are the protein bites,
coconut cashew and dark chocolate.
Actually the good fight you,
I didn't have these,
Andy Stumpf had these first and he gave
me these out of his backpack.
Where were we?
Oh in Oklahoma we had done,
we had done quite a bit of a ride on the
bikes for the day and I'm like I am
starving to death right now.
And he pulled these out of his backpack
and I just said to tell how many of
those did you bring?
And he's like,
I don't know why.
And I'm like,
those are going to be gone.
These are dynamite.
My problem is in the morning,
I'm always,
I do like too fast in the morning before
my workouts.
What?
What's the window you give yourself?
I normally don't eat until about 10 30
or 11 in the morning.
And what time do you eat at night before
you go to bed?
Seven.
Oh,
that's good.
That's a good window.
Yeah.
And honestly,
I,
I'm like
starving,
but I'm not ready to cook yet.
Or you know,
normally for my breakfast I'll normally
half an avocado to a full avocado with
anywhere from like four to six eggs.
And if I have any,
any meat leftover from the night before,
I'll slice that and have it with,
but these things on the way to the gym,
if I just feel like I don't have
anything in the tank,
these had been awesome.
They're very low glycemic index,
low sugar,
and even the protein's not ridiculous.
And when it's seven grams,
is that per byte or is that for the
whole bar?
Read that shit according to most
freaking serving samples.
Dude,
I was reading something.
Oh my God.
It says one bite.
Yeah,
1.7 servings per container too.
Yeah.
This is supposed to be one bite.
Well it's the bite is like the name for
it.
It's not supposed to be like,
how are you going to fit that whole
thing in your mouth?
To me that's a bite.
Well it's they're called protein bites.
Why wouldn't it be one square?
Cause you already bid out of it like
you've been out of.
Again,
that's two bites.
That's ridiculous.
It can't be one bite.
I mean you could do it if you had to.
If I wasn't on a podcast,
I would have done that.
Like nothing.
People get real mad by the way.
They're gonna get mad at you for chewing
on the Mike.
Can't be more annoying than Mel Gibson's
fricking pin almost shot myself in the
face for that fricking thing.
I couldn't say anything to him.
He's sitting over here,
dude,
I,
if I want a nice guy,
he's a nice guy.
He was,
but he's fried.
There's a circuit that that just hit an
overload and there's a black area where
it used to be connected to the
motherboard.
I don't know.
Well you know more than me.
Nice guy.
What's funny is,
um,
you know,
my,
one of my followers is the brand of all
Brad's.
He does all this on your podcast.
That was great podcast by the way.
He made that yesterday,
which is kind of hilarious.
John Dudley death dark your face over
Mel Gibson.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
It,
yeah,
it was funny.
But you have whatever that Penn was my
God,
that was terrible.
Yeah.
Well you know what it was,
I just don't think he could just sit and
chill.
And when Dr Neil Riordan was discussing
all this real hard,
heavy duty scientific stuff when in
regards to stem cell research and all
the different,
I mean he's had,
I mean one of the reasons why he came
on,
he wanted to come on the podcast and
people were like,
why didn't you ask him about his wife?
Why did you ask him about the,
that's not what he's here for.
I want to be respectful to the guy.
I'm a fan of Mel Gibson and he's a nice
guy.
What he asked is he said,
can I come on the podcast and talk about
the stem cell research they're doing in
Panama and the treatments that they gave
to my dad at 92 years of age.
Now he's thriving.
It almost,
it was a great podcast.
And you know,
I'm,
I'm a believer in stem cell because you
actually introduced me to doctor Rati
Mcgee in Las Vegas.
Saved,
I mean potentially you saved my archery
career.
Well,
cause we get from surgery if I will.
Yeah.
And surgeries
are fricking hit or miss.
Right,
right.
So that's what I'm saying.
I was lucky with my shoulder surgery
that I got out of there.
Good.
I know a lot of guys that are into their
third one for the same type of thing,
but literally I got
okay,
three injections the first time and went
back for a second round because I think
one of my tears didn't take.
And literally I took completely avoided
surgery because of doctrine mcgee.
And we should talk about this because I
don't know the exact specifics of what
it was called,
what the original treatment was called,
but the original treatment that you and
I both got,
he no longer baby.
Definitely quick,
quick got a baby does this past weekend,
but it's not available anymore.
It's a,
it's because they believe this is what
they're trying to make it legal.
But it has to go through a series of,
uh,
there's a whole process that it has to
get it passed because they've declared
it a drug.
Because you take the,
is something about umbilical cord stem
cells.
You take them and convert them and then
that somehow or another,
the in during the process they believe
it's become a drug.
Whatever that drug is.
I had a full length tear of my rotator
cuff.
Now this is from an MRI,
full length tear of my rotator cuff.
It was painful.
It was a real problem.
Doctor Rati Mcgee in Las Vegas,
Nevada,
shot,
whatever that baby dust is in there.
Gave you some end,
uh,
the most recent MRI that I got,
which is over a year from his original
treme.
But I knew that it felt a lot better,
but I have,
I just haven't got it checked.
It's gone.
Funny enough,
I was with you both times right the
first time,
which,
I mean,
I didn't say anything about,
but you had,
you had been struggling to shoot a lot
because you know,
you had just,
it's wearing tear.
I mean,
the bottom line is it's wear and tear
over life,
especially with you and I,
we do a lot of active stuff.
But for you to go back and you and I
went in together,
uh,
last week and when he said he looked at
you with this confused face and said,
yeah,
hey,
a new MRI that is healed,
that's fricking massive.
It's massive.
That's a tear that would have normally
absolutely required surgery or I could
have just been in pain with an unstable
shoulder.
You know,
one of the things that I'm realizing is
that over the years of uh,
essentially being engulfed in martial
arts,
most of my adult life and even into my
teenage years,
like at 15,
I became a fanatic.
Like from then on,
martial arts has always been a part of
my life.
I've done some ruthless shit with my
joints.
Both of my knees had been reconstructed.
I've had some real problems with my neck
in the past,
both of my shoulders,
f of cause of problems.
It's just explosive,
crazy shit.
Your arms are getting yanked in weird
directions,
your foot windmill,
that stuff.
That's the easiest stuff that's probably
saved me all that big foot I really
think saved me because that's shoulders
to ability because that's controlled,
you know,
all that stuff that I'm doing that's all
strengthening all these muscles around
it and that doesn't bother me.
That doesn't give me any pain.
What would give me pain is like off
angle punches.
Like you land on someone's elbow in a
weird way and you feel something
go for it right now.
Even thinking about it.
Yeah.
Getting caught in something like Kamora
and not tapping.
I've done that a bunch of times.
Like a shithead.
You're a meathead,
you know you,
you don't want to tap but you gotta tap
but you don't want you to like,
there's gotta be a way to get out of
this without tapping and then you get
out.
But then you can't do chin ups for like
three months.
That's happened 30 times in my life.
Like no joke.
Like where I didn't tap and then I was
fucked up for a few months and then I
would tape everything up and keep
rolling.
Well you,
you hooked me up with,
with Damien in Demoine for 10 planet and
I really wanted to do,
she just did classes with them,
but I'm so afraid to do it in a class
because for me it's my arms or my
career.
Right,
right.
And I mean it would literally be like
turning a light switch off in your room.
My friend Max [inaudible],
he's a professional pool player and he
said the same thing.
He was really interested in trying
Jujitsu.
So scared of getting his arm bar,
getting locked in an arm bar and fucking
his elbow or shoulder up and then he
wouldn't be able to play.
Well it's a real legitimate concern.
Two days ago,
I don't even know if I told you this,
but I'm andy texts me and she stumped.
Yeah.
He put me in a group text and needed a
closer and Jocko reached out.
We were in a group text and Jocko wants
a boat and wants lessons he wants.
So does of course he does.
So it's kind of a fucking knife in his
teeth.
What?
Full draw.
Yeah.
And he's like just make something,
he won't break in half cause he's like
he will break it.
Yeah.
And uh,
I thought Ah Shit,
if I've got to have jack over,
I know we're going to end up working out
cause if he's at my house more than two
days,
I'm not going to skip two days of
working out.
So I thought I better hit the fricking
squat rack cause I'm more of a bike guy.
Like all,
most of my leg workouts come from,
well they come from kettle bells or they
come from,
from biking because I liked the bat bike
or ruck when I thought we'll explain
ruck to people rocking is where you just
have a,
a full weighted backpack on essentially
in your just power walking.
You're almost going for an outdoor walk.
And um,
the outdoorsman,
which you actually sent to me.
Thank you.
Um,
cause I kept telling you I want to do,
you know,
some power I want to do,
like pretty much,
I want to pretend like I'm packing out
elk quarters to prepare for it.
And you said,
dude,
you gotta check out this pack.
It's called that
atlas trainer and it's available at
outdoorsman [inaudible] dot com not a
sponsor.
Just nice people that make good stuff.
They're there.
They specialize in optics,
really.
Most of their businesses and selling
high end binoculars to a hunters.
Yeah,
they're,
they're the optics authority.
They're amazing with optics.
Like they do a lot.
Have you ever listened to the Jay Scott
outdoors podcast now?
God's got a really good podcast,
super specific to hunting.
Anybody.
I mean,
it's not like this podcast where it's
like,
we'll talk about all kinds of shit and
how many dudes have little rubber muscle
men up there ass she's got,
it's not talking about any of that,
but what he's had,
cody Nelson who's one of the owners of a
outdoorsman and they go into like edge
to edge clarity,
high end details of Swarovski's Zeiss,
a vortex,
like all these different by nose and
they talk about,
you know,
all the different aspects of like
what's,
what's the best shit to buy,
what's the best shit for this price
point for that price point.
And they get like super geeky and in
depth with it,
but there's no better resource than
outdoors.
ms.com like they have everything.
They have all the high end stuff,
they're really good deals.
But they also have this,
uh,
atlas trainer,
which is because their whole thing is
western hunting.
And see when I think most people that
don't know what hunting is or did it not
in the world,
which to me prior to 2012 they think of
hunting is fucking elmer fudd some dude
with a orange vest on shooting some
poor,
innocent animal.
What western hunting is,
and this is where it gets really weird.
It's fitness with mental strength,
discipline and then hunting.
There's so much involved in it.
You're dealing with mountains,
so you have mountaineering,
hiking.
It's a tough mudder with a weapon.
It is and that's what it is.
You can only appreciate that.
I'm trying to get them to trying to get
them to,
because I become a new are absorbed like
this backpack shit that we were talking
about like what remi does on a regular
basis.
Aaron Snyder and Snyder who does a,
an amazing podcast called Kfar who cast,
it's a,
it's a Cafaro was a real high end,
a backpack company.
They make like real rugged backpack
specifically designed for hunting and
for military tactical and stuff like
that.
But Aaron Snyder,
one of the guy who runs it is a serious
hunter and he does those crazy 30 day
trips like out in the bullets,
out in the woods,
just living off your back book.
That's what Bush,
Bush and woods hanging around with.
Adam Green tree too much.
I call it the bush.
I think we're,
we've officially killed this angel's
wings.
Too much body.
What?
There's too much mass in you.
You can go through too much alcohol.
Like I have to think about you probably
wait like 40 pounds heavier than me,
so I have to have to put it in
consideration.
How much to take in.
No,
you don't.
This is great.
Podcasts are made by friends and
alcohol.
Yup.
Well that one that we did in Lanai when
it was all of us,
you and me and Ben O'brian and Sam.
So halt and have to get Shane Dorian,
Jack.
I'll go grab it.
You just keep us occupied.
Yup.
Remi uh,
Shane Dorian.
Ben O'brien,
my wife Shazzie fresh and my boy was
there.
I think I got everybody.
I think you got everybody.
Um,
we said Remi,
right?
Yeah.
Yes,
Shane,
Jack or you want to try this?
Mccowen counting Brian.
Good Little Brian.
What you want to try some local stuff?
We've got some stuff that I just got
from bigger stuff over here.
I'll,
I'll take this sucker over.
Um,
yeah,
I made a note here that was b and I have
no idea what that topic was.
We've shifted gears so many times.
This is a bauers
bauers whiskey in this from Bakersfield.
And I was just in Bakersfield.
Not a sponsor,
but not a sponsor,
but nice folks that left me in a nice
glass of a nice bottle,
rather a whiskey.
So beautiful bottle.
You know,
I didn't know this,
but that area,
Bakersfield,
like that whole area,
that's where,
um,
that's where there will be blood was all
about.
You ever see that movie?
Daniel Day Lewis?
I love that movie.
I didn't know that,
but he was amazing in that movie.
Right?
I actually really legitimately like that
movie.
Oh,
I love that to ice.
But that's all right.
We get some more ice cream.
We've got a to hook us up.
The spice that was,
that was at least 20 ounces.
Like you could die.
We're not driving.
We're going to be shooting arrows.
Luckily face no one here.
I know.
And we're surrounded by concrete
concrete.
By the way,
Dow grade is that set up by the way.
I got to thank you for hooking me up
with those uh,
block targets.
Awesome.
Only my arms are long enough to reach
across this table.
Anyone else you would have came up way
short,
Dick against the wall.
Um,
but these guys that do this,
this,
uh,
there's this hardcore back country
hunting.
It's sort of what we like what we were
talking about before it was worth,
there's levels to this and the way you
work out is to stay healthy and to be
fit in comparison to some guy like David
Goggins,
some maniac,
some campaigns type maniac,
right?
But there's,
there's levels to like everything.
Like some guys just want to go out and
try to hunt for their meat and you know,
go out and have a weekend hunt and
Wisconsin or Colorado or wherever you
guys want to put orange on for seven
days.
The other totally content with that.
And then there's guys who take it as far
as you can go.
Weirdos.
And then the Weirdos amongst the
Weirdos,
right?
Guys like Adam,
Adam Green,
true goes lives in the mountain and
facebook's the whole thing.
And instagram lives the whole thing.
Yup.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a thing.
It's not what everybody thinks it is.
It's a thing.
And I think that thing gets clouded up
by so,
so much distraction.
I think a lot of don't know what the
thing
is,
you know,
so they think of it as being some,
oh,
look at that.
A little nice.
Ooh.
Breaking ice in jre.
Is that a Yeti ice bucket?
I'll be darned.
Does it?
No,
it's a regular ice bucket.
Does you have an ice bucket and we need
an ice bucket.
Oh,
for everybody who wanted one of these,
uh,
jre tumblers,
they're gone.
Gone to 20 minutes.
I underestimated it.
Sounds like my releases.
Yeah.
I only ordered 300 of them,
but we're ordering water in 2000 now,
so I fucked up.
Sorry.
We'll get them as quick as we can.
Hopefully Yeti.
If you,
uh,
just find Ben O'bryan on instagram and
yell at them
or guy.
Cheers.
Thanks for having me out.
My pleasure,
brother.
We're,
we're prepping.
People hate that sound.
They hate to sound slurping.
They hate the sound of chewing.
I get it.
You're on the treadmill right now.
You're thinking about quitting and you
hear someone chewing,
slurp and you're like,
fuck this podcast man.
Fuck this.
Well,
I got off subject,
but what I was talking about,
I was going to do some squats just
because I felt like ready for Jocko.
Yeah,
yeah.
At least need to do one 35 ones.
Uh,
but a member the other day when I was in
Rodney's and he was ben to me all around
checking my arm when I hold a squat bar,
that is what gives me my pain right now.
Do you get massaged often?
Um,
I get,
I normally get it about four times a
year.
I have a guy that I go all the way to
Oklahoma for,
it's about 600 miles,
but his name is Lester Phillips.
Did you fly or do you drive?
I drive down there,
Geez,
yes,
name is Lester Phillips.
Ain't trying to get a massage and he's
at a,
he's actually at a,
um,
uh,
fitness building called body masters,
but he is amazing at breaking apart scar
tissue and literally getting into areas
that most people don't take the time
for.
Um,
and I normally go for two hours just for
one joint.
Jeez Christ.
But if you're sober this whole time,
yeah,
but if you're doing something well it's
arguable,
but it depends.
Um,
if you're doing something that's very
repetitive in your sport,
then those particular areas build,
you know,
it's just like I would,
a lot of times he tells me that my,
my bicep and my forearm connector on my
right side are a lot like what a
fighters are.
That's a right hand prominent where
they're having impact in the same with
my left because as you're shooting,
it's just constant hyperextension so you
build that scarring in there and when
the scarring isn't,
you know,
it's restricting the muscle from moving
properly.
You know,
he talks to me like he said,
if,
you know,
if you have long
hair and you,
and you get out of the shower,
it's not all the fibers aren't going the
same direction.
You have to like get all the knots and
stuff out of there.
So essentially he's trying to break up
those areas where the muscles aren't
flowing back and forth,
um,
smoothly.
So even though I don't have necessarily
a tear,
I feel soreness at times.
Um,
I would say maybe even a chronic
soreness,
but if I go and actually have that
broken apart,
uh,
it's extremely painful to do.
But my performance afterwards is just
night and day different.
I think you should do it a lot.
I really do.
And I,
and I,
I'm,
it's hard to find that good person
though.
That's the problem.
That's why it goes so far,
you know,
is to find someone that really,
really knows what they're doing.
Do you have a time massage place in your
town?
No.
I don't know.
I mean,
yeah,
no ties.
Make it up to Iowa.
Yeah.
This is some kind of,
I'm around here man.
And you know,
not,
not very expensive,
but amazing.
Like I had this lady that walks on my
back,
she's probably about 60 years old.
She walks about on my back,
grabs my wrists and pulls them up,
pop that back.
But she's,
she's stretches you out,
man.
It's like part of the thing,
um,
is a massage.
And then once she gets in that tissue
and loosens it up,
then she starts pulling on your arms and
stretching you out.
Time massage is legit.
It's really good holders.
Jack.
Now my best helps it.
I'm lady trying to rip your arms out of
the socket.
I'd be fucked without her.
It'd be fucked with a lot of different
things.
But that's one of them.
Yeah.
Um,
but this,
uh,
stem cell research that they're involved
in right now,
they're what they're doing right now in
Panama because it's not legal in the
United States.
That was a good podcast.
Yeah.
It was amazing.
Right.
The Guy,
Dr Neil reared,
he's very good.
He's amazing.
They just passed a significant hurdle in
Texas.
Yup.
So they're real close to being able to
do that in Texas.
And it might happen as soon as the fall.
So somewhere around,
uh,
archery season,
you might be able to go.
He's like to be able to go to Texas and
get all the same stuff that we're going
to get in Panama.
What you should do,
man,
if anybody listens to that podcast or
anybody's talking to talk,
talk to someone like me who has
benefited tremendously from it and I
haven't even gone and done what he's
doing,
which is complete next level in Panama,
but I know Tj dillashaw,
UFC bantamweight champion,
he's gone there twice now.
Fucking had massive,
massive recovery from it.
It's amazing.
We're,
we're in an incredible time when it
comes to medical science and technology
and innovation,
like what they're able to do and fix and
heal people,
you know,
that have had really significant
injuries.
That would have been a giant problem
before.
I have a friend of mine,
she works at the UFC.
My friend Heather,
she had a achilles tendon injury from
Rati.
Yes.
He did the surgery.
Yes,
and she's
six weeks later walking around without a
limp dude.
She told me that sick,
it would be six months where she would
be in a cast if it wasn't for a,
there's this new stuff that's crazy.
She's walking around without a limp.
I remember when you were in there and I
was uh,
Rodney came in and he,
he had told you about the MRI and said
it really looks like everything has
grown back together.
It's healed.
I just said that's some tron shit right
there,
dude.
I mean that's,
that's like to be able to reconstruct
something without having to go under the
knife for someone.
For me,
I went under the knife with my shoulder
and I know that the difference in
recovery between
literally not being able to almost
function a part of your body entirely
versus them saying take it easy and work
your way back into what you want to do.
Those are two pair.
I mean they're like completely different
universes,
right?
Being in a situation where you're,
you know,
one,
you have to take painkillers,
which that's not cool to having to have
someone that you're dependent on,
you know,
pack pillows under your arm and keep you
steady for three days in bed and you
can't freaking move around.
Then you got this,
you know,
big wedge under your arm and you're
walking around versus we literally went
in,
went through the process,
get an ultrasound,
they find the place to target.
You see a syringe,
literally go in,
no different than if you go and get a
tetanus shot,
you could see it in the ultrasound.
You actually watch it go in,
it goes in,
comes out,
and then it's done.
You mean,
and you literally go home and you're in
these things just go to work.
Yeah,
I mean,
I'm really,
really hopeful for the future.
And we just went into this past weekend
a rottie looked at the MRI and uh,
he was stunned at the fact that my
rotator cuffs had been completely
healed,
but I still have some little tears in
the Labor area.
So we shot some right into the joint.
But again,
what they're calm,
they're constantly innovating.
So now they're using umbilical cord
blood
and apparently they're having massive
results with umbilical cord blood and
then they're using your blood and the
PRP.
That was cool.
It's crazy to watch the machine.
Very cool.
It mixes it all up and then it and puts
it with the stem cells and it's like
we're living in the future man.
Cause I almost feel like I got gypped
that,
you know what I mean by that?
Cause it healed you.
Yeah.
I mean I had a hard time carrying a jug
of milk with my right arm.
A lot of people found that hard to
believe because,
you know,
my arms aren't small,
I don't think in average.
But,
uh,
I had a tough,
tough time carrying a jug of milk and a
hammer fist position and then got the
Mri saw few,
you know,
actually three areas where I just pretty
much abuse it and tore it apart and got
those three injections the first time
two of them took,
I ended up,
actually roddy had me back there for a
Fox News thing because I sent him a
video of me doing 60 pound curls three,
three weeks after the first stem cell
injection and I wasn't even able to
carry a jug of milk and I was doing 60
pound curls for sets,
no pain,
no pain.
So I went there and did that.
Well then it ended up slowly coming back
where I felt pain in one area of the
three.
So I had a different,
I had an injection then,
but what I had at that time was what we
referred to as a baby dust.
But now,
um,
you and my wife Sharon had prp,
which was really,
really cool to see that machine work.
PRP mixed with stem cells.
That's right.
So it's an actually,
the very first time I came in,
they had us,
um,
he asked me to do a light workout after,
but then the second time I came back,
he had me do a workout before.
Yeah.
He did that with me as well.
And then,
and then injected it.
And then we talked about the benefits of
like the sauna and what that would do
for it.
Yeah.
And then now it's already at a different
stage.
So I mean it's,
no,
there's no,
uh,
no doubt the progression of this is
just,
it's like anything,
it just gets better and better and
better and better.
What's interesting about rodey too,
what's great about Rodney,
I should say,
rather than interesting,
is that Roddy is a student of medical
science as well as a practicing
physician and surgeon.
It's a good point.
Yeah.
So he's constantly on all the latest
stuff.
He's not stagnant in any way,
shape or form.
He's constantly up on it.
So every time I have a conversation with
them,
he's like,
there's some new research coming out of
this place that shows this and he's just
constantly on the ball with it.
And so,
um,
the most latest thing was this weekend.
I mean,
last time I saw him was just a couple
months before.
It's definitely on point with the stats.
Yes.
Yeah.
We can't really match that on the
podcast.
Boy,
we were,
uh,
I was,
I had some speculation.
This activity's taking place in La and
Las Vegas rather on a daily basis what
they would be.
I was like,
my real big question was how many times
does a gay guy come in and other guy's
ass and yell out Woo in Vegas?
Oh,
how many times does he ric flair?
And Roddy was correct.
Roddy was like,
not every day.
And I think what,
I think you're right,
everybody else was like all day,
every day.
I'm like,
what are the odds?
Chamie just came alive.
This,
by the way,
this was at a very nice dinner.
We're good.
Is
that steak house?
It was very good.
Yeah.
The,
um,
shout out to craft steak at the mgm
grand chronometer was delicious.
So yeah,
games we were having some of the bay
best that Vegas could offer.
Meanwhile Joe got on some,
uh,
subjects that were probably only
probably only uh,
I dunno,
illegal to talk about in a comedy
situation.
You can talk about it anywhere now
for now,
for like the next couple of months and
then they'll make that illegal.
Yeah.
Vegas is a great place to get meals.
It's like one of the best restaurant
places in the country.
It really is.
I want a shout out to,
uh,
I want to hook up with Gordon Ramsay.
You did some,
you did some videos about hunting and
cooking wild game,
but you're missing out,
man.
You got to do this the right way.
Yeah,
that's wrong.
He's missing out on,
it was kind of a cheesy rifle hunt with
the hog.
But I think we can do way better.
And one,
I think he need to learn bow hunting
just because you're missing out if you
don't,
here's the problem.
Let me speak for Gordon Ramsay real
quick cause I met him,
I met him briefly in,
shook his hand and let's hear that.
I think I know him very well.
Let them for all 14,
15 seconds.
Uh,
he doesn't have the time,
man.
The guy's like 18 different TV shows.
I was watching them yell at some dude
who was cooking somewhere.
He was yelling.
Uh,
oddly enough the guy was cooking elk and
Gordon was complaining about the elk.
It was complaining about it being tough
and it is inevitable.
Good complaint.
And the guy aided,
he's chewing on and he said his tender
and delicious.
I'm more with the guy.
I think Gordon got a little,
he's doing a TV show up man.
Oh yeah.
I don't want to be cynical.
Is playing a character.
I don't want to be cynical,
but there's a re,
first of all,
the guy did step way over the line.
He said he was trained by some of the
greatest chefs in Europe and then Gordon
Ramsey called him on and he said,
I never said that.
And then they had video,
they played back.
So that guy's obviously a dildo.
And then on top of that,
unfortunately buddy,
sometimes in life we're delta.
I've been Deldot,
I've been a deldot more than once.
People know I haven't been deldot,
but I have been one not that way.
Not In the actual mechanical sense.
Anyway,
this guy was trying to explain,
um,
you know,
led,
he's not a chef,
but then there was video footage of him
saying that he was a chef.
But the bottom line is Gordon Ramsey,
he's playing it up and he's like talking
about how terrible the food is and
chatting on.
I'm like,
that's his show.
His show was about sort of like kitchen
nightmares.
It's like I show up and you show has to
be,
your kitchen has to be a nightmare for
kitchen nightmares.
T to work.
That's the guy.
That's the gentleman.
We don't need to play this guy.
I don't want to shame this young man,
this young man.
He's on the young man.
That's a shame.
This guy shit all over.
Awesome.
But don't you think this is a lot like a
guy who doesn't really know archery
talking shit to you?
Like your Gordon Ramsay and that guy's
guy who,
you know,
I've been finger shooting my whole life.
I don't need a release.
You know,
I don't use a site because I shoot
instinctive.
And you're like,
well,
you're just not going to be accurate.
And you're like,
no,
I'm accurate,
I'm accurate.
And then he shoots and he misses the
target and you're like,
see,
I told Ya and then,
but you're a nice guy.
Gordon Ramsey is a professional asshole.
And I don't mean that in a bad way,
but I mean when someone fucks up,
that guy comes down and you with the
hammer of truth,
it's brutal to watch.
My seven year old was so annoyed at me.
She's like,
why are you still watching this?
Because we were in the morning,
she's someone else.
She wanted a roll around on the
hoverboards and I was like,
just relax one second.
I want to see where this goes.
Because they were,
the guy was like talking about Gordon
Ramsey did not know how to cook elk.
All right.
But then I was watching him cook calc.
I'm like,
Ooh,
I don't think you know.
See,
that's what I mean.
He needs to learn.
But here's my argument.
You don't have time for archery there.
Yeah,
but I'm crazy.
Exactly.
I have a real many,
I need,
uh,
need Gordon to get crazy.
He's not going to do it.
It's not the same guy.
I think he goes at archery.
Find the people that you don't want to
think.
Actually,
it's like a game of Tetris,
right.
As well,
falling in place.
You've got to figure out where it falls
in place.
You can't foresee English.
So Gordon,
Oh,
same thing.
Give it a try.
Basically the same thing.
Yup.
Right.
Yeah.
Um,
that's her,
that's her.
I mean,
she was completely,
she had no,
literally no perspective to hunting
before we met.
I mean,
imagine Sharon and I met on a plane to
France.
We met again on the plane back from
She was from England.
I was from the u s I just happened to be
routing through Liverpool.
I said,
I appreciate,
we talked,
might not have talked about it on the
podcast,
but I think did I think,
I mean,
uh,
but it's a great story.
Yeah.
It is a very good story,
better.
And then you're like,
damn,
why didn't get her number?
And then you met her again.
Hollywood.
We need a movie called love at first
flight.
This is it.
You can uh,
have nicholas cage play an archer.
But I'm just going to go out on a limb
which say terrible job.
She is from England does not mean that
they're the same thing that him and her
just like already laying is also from
America and he is not as same as me.
We are different.
He has way more experience with
pharmaceutical drugs and heroin.
And I have a more experience shooting
animals with a pole and Arrow and it
will always be such,
yeah,
do whatever you want to do in this life.
You know,
I don't think he needs to go out and
hunt with a bow and arrow.
The one thing is it would require a
tremendous learning curve.
Right?
Especially like my first experiences
were,
uh,
bears over Bait,
which is a much easier proposition.
It's a very controlled situation.
But is,
I mean,
I think controlled situations are
important for any beginner.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
Sure.
Right.
Sparring,
when you teach people how to fight,
one of the first things I suggest always
they spar and advanced belt.
They spar.
Someone's not going to hurt them.
Well,
mark talked about that at dinner.
We talked about a sparring.
Yes.
Right.
Yeah.
And we can,
you can read it.
Mark and I,
we,
we haven't asked the brain.
Yeah.
Mark and I actually,
uh,
I,
I played a video for him that I was
really disturbed about.
We,
we actually played it yesterday on the
podcast.
Did you have,
it's a heavy virgil.
I haven't watched it yet.
No.
Yesterday wasn't surgical.
Brendan Shab and Brian Kale,
we talked about,
um,
heavy sparring that there's guys that
are hitting each other as hard as they
possibly can.
And all that is,
is like an ego exercise.
You're not,
you're not getting better.
You're hurting each other.
You're fucking each other's brains up.
And Mark and I were talking about that,
like how many guys get turned off to
sparring because they spar with someone
who just beats the shit out of him in a
bad gym rather than spars with someone
who teaches you just to get touched.
You just get touched in the face.
So you know you got hit,
you know,
and someone who's fast but has control
and then you learn how to operate
without the,
the fear and consequences of like a wild
Jim Brawl,
which is like really common.
A lot of gyms,
they have brawls where it should be just
sparring,
but instead you're really just fighting
all the time.
You're fighting constantly.
Those people always wind up with brain
damage,
like almost always.
So Real,
real issue with a lot of,
um,
low level gyms or gyms where people
haven't really considered the
consequences of their actions.
Did you uh,
yeah.
That's fine.
Did you play that video that you showed
when we were at dinner?
The other guy get knocked out?
Is that what it want?
Yeah,
that's the one.
Yeah.
Mark was like,
this would never happen at his gym.
Never happened.
Mark's amazing.
I think it's important.
I mean,
any type of,
any type of beginner needs a controlled
situation and you need training wheels.
I mean,
yeah,
it's important and there's that feeling,
well this is what I've been preaching
forever,
is that feeling of not knowing how to do
something and trying to figure it out is
crucial.
As a human being,
I think we're human stagnate.
That feeling makes people feel weird.
They don't like being a loser.
They don't like being a beginner.
They don't like it.
But I think that feeling is crucial
because when you get really good at
something and you get stagnant and you,
you don't worry about it anymore,
there's no growth,
there's no movement.
You know?
There's something about that that's very
detrimental to the human psyche.
It's very detrimental to your growth and
your a constant self examination,
which a lot of people don't like,
but I think is important.
This is why I think it's,
I think it's important for peace of mind
because I think it may bring rocky
moments where you,
you don't like what you find and you
just feel like,
God,
can I just just,
just be cool with everything and real.
But I think through that path,
those rocky moments,
you get to understand yourself in a very
pure way versus understanding the
projection of who you would like people
to think you are,
which is what most people exist in.
Most people exist in this world of
slippery shoes and shiny fucking cars
and ties and wearing the right things
and saying the right things.
All those things are sort of designed to
project an image that's not necessarily
you.
It's a cheap way of getting people to
think greater of you.
Whereas the only way that people think
that the really know who you are is see
you doing something hard,
see,
see you doing something difficult.
They don't know who you are.
If you show up and the,
the camera's start flash and you're on
the red car,
but you're in the perfect suit,
you hop out of a limo.
You've got a gorgeous girl and your arm
don't know Jack Shit about that.
It looks amazing.
I'd like to be that guy.
Everybody would,
but they don't know God damn thing about
you,
but if they saw you at mile 59 of a 200
mile race and you're shitting yourself
over a cactus in the middle of the
funnel,
in the middle of the mountains,
the campaigns,
then then they would know who you really
are and I think this is also one of the
reasons why a guy like you,
you're hesitant close to yes,
my litmus sex is hunting.
Well it's,
I mean not hard.
If I'm,
if I ever really am at a point where I
feel like is this going to be a
legitimate friend or is this going to be
someone that I just do business with,
then that's,
that's where I test it is in something
tough because those people,
to me,
those people put themselves,
you're probably the same.
There's maybe six or seven people that I
talk to on a daily basis and then
there's like a different tier to that,
but that is my litmus test.
If,
if people can can do those things and
really proved themselves like at the
tough,
tough times.
If you handle it.
Yeah.
If they can handle it.
Those are the people that I want around
me.
That's the tree for fuel,
right know.
Yeah,
because when you're ready to be like,
should I just take a break right now and
they're still going.
You're like,
I'm not going to let him beat me cause
he was going to ride me at the end.
Have you seen ever seen Jockos video?
It's just called good.
Ah,
you haven't seen it play at Jamie.
Find that.
It's one of my favorite videos on the
Internet.
There's a lot of videos on the Internet.
Crazy isn't the world that Jacko and I
met in
an,
we literally pass each other in an
airport.
Pretty crazy.
Took,
we both had a just enough time to take a
selfie and we texted it to you.
Remember that?
Yes.
Yeah.
It was amazing.
Let's,
we're going to play it because this one
thing I know the Jocko would never flag
us off youtube.
One of my direct subordinates,
one of my guys that worked for me,
he would,
he would call me up or pull me aside
with some major problem,
some issue that was going on and he'd
say,
boss,
we got this and that and the other
thing.
And I look at him and I'd say,
good.
And finally one day he was telling me
about some issue that he was having some
problem and he said,
I already know what you're going to say.
I said,
well,
what am I going to say?
You said you're going to say good.
Uh,
he said,
that's what you always say when
something is wrong in going bad.
You always just look at me and say good.
And I said,
well,
yeah,
when things are going bad there's going
to be some good that's going to come
from it.
Didn't get the new high speed gear we
wanted.
Good,
didn't get promoted.
Oh,
mission got canceled.
Good.
We can focus on our own,
didn't get funded,
didn't get the job you wanted.
Got Injured,
sprained my ankle,
got tapped out.
Good,
got beat.
Unexpected problems.
We have the opportunity to figure out a
solution.
That's it.
When things are going bad,
don't get all bummed out.
Don't get startled.
Don't get frustrated.
If you can say the word good,
guess what
need.
You're still alive.
It meets.
You're still grieving and if you're
still breathing,
you still got some fight left it.
Come on,
get up,
dust off,
reload,
recalibrate,
reengage.
Go out on the attack.
Come on
Sun.
Dang.
If that doesn't make you find out,
oh,
you need to go to a doctor.
Can people hear that on the podcast?
If like downloading the itunes that hear
that for sure.
Yeah,
we're playing that.
Listen,
if you listen to an empty friends in
here,
I'd punch someone in the face,
right?
I want to shoot a broadhead through
someone's neck.
That's what Jocko is all about.
Man.
When I run,
I literally hear that sometimes when I'm
fucking exhausted,
I'm going to hit the high hills.
Never ran to that.
If I did,
I'd,
I wouldn't even be here right now.
Die of a heart attack somewhere out of
fricking had a cardiac arrest.
I don't listen to it too.
When I run because I really believe that
listening to music when you're running
is cheating.
Why?
Why try?
Cause that's easier.
Are you kidding?
I'm serious.
Yeah.
Well I think that when you run,
it should be in your mind.
You should be,
you're such an issue with your thoughts
alone.
And I think that when you run and you
listen to music,
it's easier.
Therefore it's cheating.
I'm pissed right now.
Last time,
two homos running with your walkmans
with your ear plugs on.
Alright,
go five miles.
Then their ear buds.
You think it's different?
It's different to go two miles and five
miles to do.
You need,
I can do two miles in 20 minutes.
Right?
But can you do two miles in the hills?
Tribe miles is probably easier to to,
it's just overall,
it's as longer distracting an hour.
Right?
So you have to listen to music.
You,
Brittany Spears gets you through the
last three.
Don't have to,
it helps with like the mind games.
Sure.
I'm sure.
But that's the whole idea.
It's cheating.
I'm pissed.
So I was wearing shoes then.
Yes,
you're right.
You're right.
It is wearing.
Wearing shoes is cheating.
What?
Yeah,
you should be careful.
Here we go.
We were watching a video the other day
that Jamie almost made me throw up.
It was a dude who was carving off of his
callouses with a knife.
He had cows that were so thick.
He had a knife out and he was carving
the cows off and then a dog was eating
them.
Well,
I don't know about the dog eating part,
but I've definitely carved up calluses.
Ever seen counselors like this?
I mean,
I dunno.
This guy looked like he'd been walking
barefoot for several years.
I'm just pissed because last time I was
here you talked about the fact
that's it.
Would I talk about last?
Do we have that coin flipped over
saying,
yes,
please.
Oh,
the Brazilian Shahaz Korea coin.
Look at this.
Fucking,
come on.
Look at this.
It carving off chunks of his callous
with a fucking knife dude,
and the dog's going to eat that.
Of course he will says,
man cuts calluses off his foot with
calyces.
That's all dead foot like Mr Deeds is on
youtube right now.
He's moving around though.
He's alive.
Look at that.
Look at this.
Come on son.
It's got a goddamn fillet knife.
She,
anyone who's anyone who's watching with
the podcast,
anyone who's listening to this podcast
bring up please youtube.
This dog dog's going to eat it.
That's a starving dog.
I liked that.
Beagle dogs confused.
It's like,
am I?
He's like,
is this blue cheese or is this humans?
It's this blue cheese.
There's just a little trimmed.
It's a hard video to get over.
I thought I saw that video.
I had to take a leak at like five
o'clock in the morning.
I try.
I always do this,
man.
I was,
I'm thirsty at night and I'm like,
you shouldn't drink because if you drink
then you going to wake up in the middle
of the night.
You're going to have to pee.
You know that thing,
but on my bed,
I'm thirsty.
Fuck it.
I'll deal with that later.
I'm going to live in the moment kind of
guy.
Oh yeah,
and if I've got your pen and all I'm
thinking about when I'm painting,
I'm shaking my head thinking about that
dude chopping cows is off his foot with
a goddamn cleaver.
I like that.
I think they could serve that with a
cheese plate.
That guy probably runs barefoot like,
well,
last time I was here serious calcis you
talk to me about having kettlebells and
random places so that as you walk by him
you can just grab them,
do a few sets,
go to failure,
right?
Yeah.
Now you're fricking running with no
music because it makes it tough or yeah.
I don't want to be a pussy.
All those people running with music.
You heard me?
People listen to the Rogan podcasts
right now while they're running.
Turn it off.
So some kidding Jesus Christ.
I don't really think your pussy.
I listened to music all the time when
I'm on an elliptical machine.
If that makes you feel better.
You told James Hatfield but Hetfield
that you listened to his podcasts that
more or is a new record that morning
until you,
you're working out?
I did,
yeah.
It was in the gym lifting.
That's your pussy.
It came from a town make that mongoose
bike.
I like the fact that we talk is still
going hard.
I mean they like 85 years old.
I went to their concert and I will,
my buddy torsten,
his wife Trina,
she works for q prime,
hooked me up on some tickets to the
metallica concert in Iowa dam and they
freaking rocked.
See what does this,
this guy him from metallica on the world
wide tour.
Get rid of the Goddamn pop up son of a
bitch.
I know.
What is this?
Jim Brewer is actually the one who oh,
there he is.
Oh,
another popup.
Jesus Christ.
Welcome to the world.
We live in.
Pop it.
People are so greedy.
Crazy.
Yesterday Sharon was looking,
cause I'm still,
I still have my real wedding ring on the
wedding ring.
I have mine too.
I know.
But have you seen any of those weird uh,
videos of people stripping their fingers
off on pull up bars and stuff?
I have a friend who had to get an
operation,
not friend.
Uh,
dude,
I know who had to get an operation
because uh,
while he was doing Jujitsu,
now he knows he's not on the list.
Well,
I know.
Um,
but I don't know him.
I don't have his number.
Okay.
I don't have your number or your email
and never emailed him.
Anyway,
his,
uh,
his wedding ring bent and dug into his
finger while I was training something
happened.
Imagine how strong like an arm bar has
the knee or the pressure on your joints,
whatever the fuck it was.
But it dug into his fingers so deeply
that he had to get it sorted.
Jitsu been terrain Jujitsu.
Oh my God.
Indeed.
What do you got pictures to Jitsu but
not happen to Jimmy Fallon,
like
injury that caused ring ambulation bout
with ring ambulation of finger injury.
That looks and sounds like something
from a horror movie.
Okay.
Let's suppose that was his wedding ring
as well.
Yes.
Rip The skin off his whole finger.
I think I'm down.
I'm down for the Tattoo.
I'll get that bone.
I'll get that queer red wedding a,
you know that tattoo that guys get.
I've tried to get it,
but they talked us out of it.
Two different tattoo places said it was
the jinx said if he,
if you do it,
it's like the curse.
That's not true.
My friend Big John McCarthy has that
shit.
He's been married forever.
Happily married.
It's give a time.
Nah,
sorry John.
How long can it last?
I mean,
he's almost dead.
I'm just kidding.
I Dang.
That's ruthless.
He's super nice.
He's the,
I've met him.
He's the guy.
He's Super Nice,
but I'm just kidding.
She brings her archaic.
You know there,
there's a company that makes a rubber
ring.
Yeah,
yeah.
Literally.
That's what I was talking about.
Yes.
I tried to put that shit on.
My wife had spit my face.
Here's what's weird.
My Sharon was going to buy me that four
just because I kept telling her like,
I'm worried about ripping this finger
off.
Right.
Mainly because of my wedding ring is
definitely too small,
so she was looking at some of those,
a silicone rings and we were literally
looking at it on her ipad in my kitchen.
I open instagram and started looking.
It's like sponsored ad buy that ring
company.
Isn't that what's weird?
It's very weird.
We were just talking about that.
We're just talking about that the other
day that we stuff you Jamie and whoever
was on the podcast we were talking about
like having a conversation and if you
have like Alexa or if you have like
certain things that like listen to you
while you're talking like maybe even
possibly Siri and then all of a sudden
you'll go to google and what you were
talking about like slick trick
broadheads or some shit like that will
show up in your Google ads.
You're like,
what in the fuck?
Maybe series series a total fricking.
She is a peeping Tom.
He's a two face little Ho.
She,
I don't think she's too faced.
I think Shay Siri,
she doesn't have a single face.
You're a two faced bitch.
Oh,
you're not connected.
Is that a bad thing though?
I know it.
It's weird and it's that bad.
I mean at at potentially you could view
that as something like,
I would probably want to buy that and
now that it's here in an easier way for
me to do it,
that is kind of,
I'm just going,
Jamie,
if you say,
Oh my God,
I'm gonna die out here.
At that time,
Siri can step in and say,
would you like me to call a helicopter?
But when you're looking at rubber rings
for your wedding ring and then it shows
up on your laptop.
Yeah.
At that point he's a sell.
Get to the bottom of this.
Well,
it most certainly exists with Google
because I've,
I've looked at like,
what are you?
Cheers.
I've looked at some,
you're milking it over there.
I'm all right.
Sadly,
I smoked pot though.
You didn't.
Oh,
you did a little sh.
Don't tell any sponsors.
I might've made that last part up.
This.
The problem is like you'll be looking at
something super obscure like a,
like a casio watch sound like casio.
That's Cassio.
Yeah.
All right.
It's,
it has its good one.
I like this one.
It's like a pro tech and that totally
doesn't limiter and a an accomplice in
it.
Totally.
It doesn't look like it.
It is a casio Lord.
Come on.
Well,
no shit
but the eye,
but then all of a sudden it'll show you
whatever you search for,
whatever it was,
whether it's surf ports or fucking Hilda
Berg tents.
There'll be for sale and you'll see like
amazon.com ads for like what?
Like I was looking at Zeiss by knows the
other day I read.
Talked about it.
Yes,
actually,
yeah,
but then I read a review on them and I
actually googled them,
but then like everywhere I went,
if I went online,
I would see a little google ad for Zeiss
by knows.
I'm like,
this is kind of creepy,
but that's different.
I think if you google search it,
you're on the grid.
You are.
If you're on someone else's device in
your home kitchen,
it's not like I was looking at it on
mine.
Right.
I was on Sharon's Ipad then,
oh,
she was ordering me a ring on her ipad
and we were talking about it.
Then I opened my instagram up and hears
the silicone rings as a sponsored
recommendation within my instagram feed.
Yeah,
he's backing up.
You gotta back it up,
back it up.
Oh,
I want a drink of water.
Go back to that.
Gmail is free for a reason.
These are all free services we're using
and not paying for,
so you have to give up a little bit to
get these cool things to give up your,
I get it.
Your privilege.
Here's my position.
My whole,
everything I think of is out there.
I'm a professional talker.
Every,
every the most fucked up ideas I've ever
had have all been recorded.
Very true.
100% true.
There's no getting around that.
Like I don't have any highly put some
crazy stuff.
Anybody would anybody I,
I'm telling you,
there's nothing special about me.
Anybody would,
if you didn't have a job and you had
enough free time and you were worried
about paying your bills and we'd have to
think you are,
you were in tune with the universe.
Anybody would,
we all would.
It's nothing special me.
Cheers
Andy.
Powerful
about that.
Freak jumping off cliffs flying around
and posted his video today.
I know you want some of that.
No.
Good.
Good for you.
I'm glad you stay away from this.
This is a bad drug.
Is the God that this is a drug that
government doesn't approve of.
California does.
Jeff sessions was in town today.
Kick grief.
Who's telling people?
Stop letting Mexicans are watching this.
It's actually five feet away from me,
but it looked like a fog machine and
Hollywood right there.
Like some horror movie.
Yeah.
Do you know,
um,
remember when I talked,
have you ever listen to my podcast with
Mike's linkerd with hex?
Yes.
I've listened to every podcast you've
ever done.
That's crazy.
Knock on.tv.
That's not done.
Not Gone.
Podcast.
Yeah.
Nope.
Um,
Mike actually went to Dr. McGee.
Did he?
Yeah,
he couldn't pull his boat for almost a
year because he had so many problems in
the shoulder and he was really dreading
the surgery because he was worried about
his downtime and I told him like,
man,
you need to to call Rati because there's
a possibility you don't need the knife.
And so he went down there and he ended
up getting in an injection I think in
September or October,
and then he came hunting with me in
November and we actually shot together
and he goes,
this is the first time I've been able to
shoot my boat in a long,
long time.
It's crazy.
Wow,
that's amazing.
It's just so cool that there's something
like that out there for people and
there's a bunch of different versions of
it.
I know people that have had really good
results where some places they take the
stem cells out of your fat.
They like to give you a little baby
liposuction,
pull some fat out,
take the stem cells,
mix it up,
shoot it into joints.
People who had real positive results
with that.
It's weird that we ha we did it the way
we did it with the blood,
but then there's also the out of the
bone marrow,
which is supposed to be more painful.
It's supposed to be more painful,
but it's also supposed to be really
effective.
Ah,
Daniel Cormier had that done.
He had real good results with that.
He had that done with a knee injury and
uh,
he was concerned like I think I believe
on,
on to speak out of school.
I'm pretty sure it was an MCL wasn't um,
the big one.
It wasn't the acl.
The acl is the big one.
That's a tough one because that's the
stabilizer one.
That's the one that goes through the
center of the knee.
I blown,
blown both of those out heavy.
Really?
Yeah.
Even both cut on or,
yeah,
both of them reconstructed.
Yeah.
The first one I had done where they take
a chunk of your patella tendon with a
piece of your knee cap and a piece of
your Shin and they open you up like a
trout and they fucking screw that baby
in.
I don't know if I've ever seen the front
of your knee cap.
Yeah,
you can see it.
There's like,
that's a big cut.
Normally get those barbell jeans up.
These are by the Belgians minor to also
not a sponsor.
You can kind of see they're awesome
guys.
Well,
it's a great product.
There's calf out there that I'm not
flexing and that's just what my calf,
I am,
I'm not,
I have large your flex.
I'm the rock.
I'm not at all.
Look,
look,
see,
I'm losing.
I'm very loose.
Flicks him.
Um,
so I wanna look cool.
This is great now,
but it was,
it was in pain for a year.
A solid year.
Like I couldn't kneel net,
no kneeling.
There was no kneeling going on.
If I had to suck Dick,
I'd be in real trouble.
I have to lie on the bed.
Let it do not my face.
There was no way I'd be able to say
that's the alcohol talking.
The point is,
it was painful.
But the other one that I had done a,
I had it done with a another planet.
I had it done with a cadaver and that
way,
way easier.
Yeah.
That was ways you're in,
but way weirder because you're thinking
about it.
You get some dead person's parts in your
body.
My father,
well,
I shouldn't say that.
Sharon stepdad has a pig heart and he's
pretty proud of it.
Wow.
He has a pig heart grew it in a pig.
What you mean it's a pig heart like it's
his,
no,
they used a pig valve in his heart.
Okay.
They can't do that with a whole heart.
I don't think so.
But they can do with parts.
Right.
Pigs are super similar apparently to
people with certain organs to the point
where they think that there might be a
time where we,
uh,
use genetic engineering to manipulate a
pig to grow a human body.
Parts what?
Yeah,
they're real,
they're real close apparently to
figuring out a way to combine human.
They're scientists grow bullish on paid
to human transplants.
Jamie just pulled up an article.
It's Baltimore.
It's the website
science mag.org.
And uh,
this is something that they've apparent.
There's apparently enough similarity.
This is coming from a dummy,
by the way,
settle down enough similarity between
pigs and humans that we might be able to
grow their organs,
grow our organs rather inside of them.
And so like if you need to,
if he needed a new liver or a kidney or
if you needed maybe even a heart,
something they could possibly grow it
inside of this genetically altered pig
cause they're really close to us.
It's Freaky Shit,
man.
It's definitely freaky.
It's freaky shit because,
uh,
one of the things that I've gotten more
and more adamant about from,
um,
being around wild animals,
is that that's really the only way
animals should be.
I mean,
there's one thing like your dog like
shades.
Yup.
I don't want the shades to be wild.
She's a sweetie.
Right.
You know what I mean?
She wouldn't make it.
That's a different thing.
She wouldn't make it different thing.
Pat is a different thing and anybody
thinks to start a different,
that's a family member.
Uh,
my pets are family members,
my dog,
my,
you know,
if,
if I have an interaction with a dog,
it's like I love them.
And this is not the same as,
um,
the way I feel about
a wild thing.
Wild thing.
I want to be wild.
Really want them to be wild because I
just think that we fucked up.
We got real comfortable with this way of
a raising and treating life outside of
our own species.
Even her own,
she would argue.
Sure.
Right,
and you'd be right.
You've been around.
Even her own has been,
I think the whole,
I think the whole picture is completely
different now.
People won't get it.
I mean we want our,
our pet dog to be part of our family,
but the reality is if they were
legitimately out there in the wild,
they would be dead quick.
My kids got rabbits,
they're useless.
They don't give a fuck about these
rabbits,
which we talked about this in favor like
we have to give rabbits,
but okay,
okay,
we'll get rabbits.
They don't give a fuck about those
rabbits.
They go like a week without even looking
at those things.
They just don't care.
And the rabbit stay chill with the
chickens in the chicken coop.
So everybody's good rabbit's,
you're having a good old time.
They're selfish too.
Here's the thing,
what rabbit is,
is a small prey animal that has to
dapped its environment.
So if its environment,
it's just them being outside by
themselves all the time.
Well,
as you expected them to be domesticated,
they're basically wild in the cage.
You know,
they're not constantly getting direct
contact with people,
but don't you think some people could be
argued the same?
You have for sure,
but a button.
But he was the one,
I haven't let you see this yet.
I'll let you finish your point.
This is just such a difference between
them and a dog.
Like the idea of that a rabbit interacts
with you with the way it fucking dog
does is bananas.
You're losing me if you don't tell me
you like dogs more than you like
rabbits.
I can't talk to you because I've got
dogs that are like little people.
All right.
I mean they're,
they're like when my friends like
Marshall's,
my friend,
he's a one year old friend that I have.
I have one friend who's one years old.
This dude and he's literally your best
friend and he,
there's like,
do nothing separating you from his best
friend.
No,
we're,
we're super tight.
We're like this.
As long as he doesn't steal food off the
table,
which she will if I'm not looking.
That's your side
to his side.
He's 100% dedicated unit.
Even if you stoled food from his side,
he would still be your best friend the
next day.
100% he's just gotta know the rules can
be stealing food,
can be climbing on the table and he
fucking savage like dogs would just jump
on the table and just,
you don't realize how like,
oh that's a course.
That's is the food is,
why would he jump up there?
It's amazing you've been able to stop
him from jumping up there.
The moment he gets in the room.
That's what's really amazing.
Here's what's crazy though.
If people had to really go out in the
world and defend them,
fen defend themselves like our dogs
would that are technically family
members,
there would be a very clear line drawn.
Yes,
but they don't and that's why we're
delusional.
And then there's movies,
Disney movies,
Bambi,
all that crazy shit.
Yogi and booboo.
But Molly's that rabbit movie.
Cause when we got on this subject,
most recent one?
No.
Sharon brought up that movie that was
like the darkest kids movie.
Does it ted?
No,
it was,
it was a rabbit movie.
Rabbit movie.
What was the name of it?
Look it up,
Jamie.
It was like,
it was considered one of the,
I don't know,
one of the darkest kids movies.
It was where it was all about rabbits
and I'm trying to think of the name of
it.
It was,
I don't even know what that is.
I,
there was a youtube video showing pretty
much,
it was like a highlight reel of that
movie and it was too,
I think a mirror inland Manson song and
it was crazy.
It was pretty dark.
I think it was called bright eyes or
maybe that was the theme song to the
movie.
Bright Eyes.
A dark rabbit.
Mophie dumb,
dumb,
dumb.
Seriously.
You need to look that up on Youtube.
Little by a right eyes.
Imagine fuck bigfoot Matt.
Just seven foot rabbit.
I tries to bite your head off with those
giant teeth.
I don't know,
seven foot rabbit.
I don't know if I'd be that terrified,
terrified.
Seven foot Grizzly,
I'd be way more terrifying.
Sure.
Seven foot crocodile way more terrified.
Okay.
Komodo Dragon.
Did you find it?
What does leadership down?
Maybe that's it.
That's it.
Pressing rabbit moving it is to die.
Remember this,
he needed to watch this.
Wow.
Watershed Cam trailer.
If we play it,
we'll get yanked off of youtube.
But can you play that?
Uh,
we can't play any clips today.
It's crazy today.
What's going on?
Well,
after the hold up,
it's not,
go ahead and take a,
take a leak.
Hey Jamie,
that while we're talking about
alligators or crocodiles,
you gotta see this?
This is actually,
um,
one of the guys that dragons,
yeah.
This is a new short film coming up.
This is one of the guys that is,
he documents wildlife,
um,
that mouth and he's,
he's a hex advocate,
but he wasn't a hex advocate first.
He was a,
well,
let's explain what hexis you can explain
it.
A hecs rather is a,
it's a company that makes um,
these suits that apparently the idea is
that they block and electro magnetic
frequency that people admit is that I
saying,
yeah,
you're good and electromagnetic current.
There's something body emits that they
think John Dudley has left the room.
He has to pee.
I don't know.
This is the,
the most honest way I can say this.
Um,
John is a big believer in this heck
system and I don't know if it works but
I know a lot of people think it works
and there is a task that they use where
there's a machine,
see if he could find,
they have a video of him explaining how
it works.
And in the video it says it in there.
There's a,
on the website there's a video link.
See the video link?
Yeah.
Um,
see where it says videos.
Uh,
third from the,
yeah,
there is um,
there's something where they show the,
they can swipe their arm over some sort
of a machine that is designed to detect
electrical current that comes from your
body.
And they do it with just a normal arm
with like a shirt on and then they do it
with this heck suit on and the heck suit
it blocks whatever that frequency is.
And so the idea is that we're assuming
that somehow or another the animals
might have some sort of method of
detection by way of the actual
electrical energy that's come from a
person.
Do I know if that's correct?
I do not.
I do not know if that's correct.
It's fascinating to think of though,
because I wonder how many different
animals have this interesting sort of
ability to detect things other than just
smelling and seeing.
Like maybe there's a feel,
maybe they have a feel and apparently
these things are particularly effective
with predators,
which kind of makes sense.
I guess that predators would,
it would feel the electrical frequency
that's coming from a UN nervous scared
animal or something he's trying to run
from it.
And um,
these things are really effective
apparently with coyotes.
And this is this documentary or this
little short film rather,
uh,
dances,
dancing with dragons.
Perfect timing.
I just explained hacks to a t.
I'm a wizard without knowing shit,
barely got through high school.
This is,
um,
so apparently this signal,
whatever the,
the human signal is,
I mean that the fact that they can
detect it in this machine and I've
watched that detection,
it's real.
It's legitimate.
So something's happening that the
machine detects.
I think we'd be foolhardy to believe
that animals can't detect that as well.
Now is that mean that it will work on
everything and no,
believer,
I'm a believer too,
but this is what I think.
I think it's,
there's a whole,
there's so many factors when it comes to
getting close to an animal.
I think they have so many senses.
I think they could smell in some insane
way that we can't even imagine.
They can hear shit.
We can never here.
They're just tuned in the idea that that
would be it.
That they wouldn't have some other shit
that we haven't really thought of.
This would be a good guest for you.
[inaudible] name is forrest Scullin.
Tay is actually,
um,
he's got some really cool stuff coming
up that I'm not able to talk about,
but I,
I know you and now tell me the things
over.
I know you enough to know that it's in
your wheelhouse,
but,
uh,
this is all a hundred percent wild,
I think,
I don't want to say it wrong,
but I think it's at a certain place down
south of Mexico.
This,
yeah.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So this,
um,
he had,
he just had a documentary that came out.
He's in a document,
he's in a heck suit that actually has a
pattern that resembles the saltwater
crocodiles.
Wow.
Did you notice that part?
I did not want,
but I only did once you brought it up,
I was mimicking,
he's mimicking the behaviors of a
saltwater croc so that he can literally
be within a few inches of them.
So did they wa they would probably be
real dangerous to try that even the way
he did it.
But did they try it without the heck
suit?
Like did they try like a,
like a rash guard that with the same
exact
pattern on it?
Yeah.
There's,
there's,
there's a lot of really good videos
showing the difference between how much
interaction you can have with certain
animals that,
especially ones that have,
it's scientifically been proven to test
to sense it.
Yeah.
So you know,
in the wildlife community things like
sharks and shark week obviously have a
huge amount of funding behind it.
A migratory birds,
same thing.
So all that stuff.
There's been very good documentation on,
you know,
electromagnetic fields and what animals
can see.
But when it comes to like the hunting
community,
obviously there's not a lot of big
funding behind it because it's a much
smaller community.
But things like this,
things that are on animal planet or
Discovery Channel,
I mean these are things that are at I
think a higher level of maybe testing
versus what we have in the hunting side.
And I just know that me personally as a
hunter,
I've experienced more like up close
interaction with it.
So I just find some of this stuff
really,
really cool,
all
that,
that's like a placebo effect that you
may be just,
we're in a really good spot with really
good wind.
And you had a few experiences,
so you put it together and he said,
this is what's happening.
Is it possible?
It's possible,
but in the same sense,
I'll leave that up to you.
I think it's possible too,
but I just want,
I brought it up
because I think,
I think it's possible,
but I think people want one or the
other.
Right.
And I think it's also entirely possible
if there's a machine that can detect
your electrical magnetic frequency or
whatever the fuck that is.
When they do it over that machine to
there is there is and I've seen it.
Yeah.
Okay.
So what's happening there and why are we
assuming animals can't see that?
Definitely didn't see at night.
They could see at night.
Right?
They do things that we can't do.
They smell things.
We can't smell the hear things we can't
hear.
We have intuition.
Why would we assume that their intuition
is not thousands of times sharper than
ours?
They're running away from fucking
crocodiles and shit.
Do you know that?
Um,
I know when you did the podcast with
James Hetfield,
you guys talked about bees a lot.
Do you know that bees when they go to
and from certain flowers that actually
they leave in an electromagnetic
signal on that part so that actually
other bees can see that and know that
something is another b had already been
there to pollinate that area.
Oh,
I've got a video I can show you that
actually shows that.
But um,
did I ever tell you about my experience
with bees on fear factor?
Yeah.
Super Cool.
They got together,
this was a crazy moment.
They had trained be communication
contests.
These bees of this guy had brought in
who's a beekeeper and then while we were
doing the stunt on these people and they
put the bees on these people,
all of a sudden this local beehive
emptied out and came to visit and they
all,
all the bees got together in the middle
of the sky and talked and we had a sit
down for like a half an hour.
The guy was like,
you know,
we're not gonna do anything.
We're going to do that.
We have to step back and let them work
this out.
So he just knew.
He knew how like these alien beings
we're going to communicate with each
other,
how they're figuring out their life
forms,
man.
And we're just like,
oh it's just bs.
No it's on,
it's a little weird life form that can
fly that somehow under the figures out
they exchange information with these
other weird life forms.
They realize,
hey we don't,
we didn't ask to be here.
We're not trying to take over your
community.
We just,
we showed up cause we're doing fear
factor.
He know the wiggle dance.
The little thing that bees do,
the wiggle dance,
what is that?
They say that's,
they assume that's that that's actually
an electromagnetic dance that's done to
where it gives a signal to the other
bees to where they can actually know
what they're communicating so they can
say things.
Yep.
Did they know like how complicated the
speech can be?
Well,
I mean,
obviously if a bee is sitting in a hive
in my Bush out in my front yard and he
knows to go three blocks down and two
blocks over and get into
those purple flowers that are in
someone's front yard,
they must know pretty dang good
too.
They know.
I mean,
we just,
we just left.
They had a heck suit on.
They probably wouldn't be able to figure
it out,
be screwed.
That's an interesting idea,
man.
That there is really some sort of
electrical fee.
Whoa.
Electrical fields of flowers.
Jane simulate the sensory hairs of
bumblebees.
Holy Shit,
dude.
Heck seen on a bumblebee.
And he's like,
nothing's getting pollinated.
Listened what that says electrical
fields of flowers stimulate the sensory
hairs of Bumblebee.
So their hairs are feeling where the
wind is pulling them.
They're,
they're feeling some sort of electrical
charge to a certain little,
little green,
the dance solid fuck man,
that is,
we're just,
because they can't send emails,
they don't do anything.
That's really,
we weave so slept on bays.
They're dying off like they're crazy
because they're super cool.
These are super,
they're super cool.
Yup.
Yeah.
People that don't give a fuck about bees
like those are like the most hardcore,
the most hardcore radical Republican
guys.
All right,
we'll figure out mechanical piece.
Don't worry about it.
There was a black mirror,
just people that are like that.
Man.
That was a good show dude.
He started sharing and I started
watching it because of you.
Did you watch the dog one with the robot
dogs?
Yeah,
we watched them.
It was a fucking terrifying show,
right?
Cause you're like,
oh,
this is all like,
well,
within the realm of possibility,
all of it.
It's almost like a warning show.
It's like gay Fuckos.
This is what could go wrong.
Every episode of that.
Did you see the one with The v?
I don't want to give any spoilers or
words with the video game that they put
a chip in your brain.
You see that one?
Yup.
Holy Shit Man.
That's 100% going to happen.
It's going to happen.
Oh my God,
we're so fucked.
We're so fucked.
It's going to have bad.
It will get bad.
It's going to get really good too.
I think it's the,
it's at the same time.
Yeah,
that is true.
I think it's going to get weird and it's
going to get really good.
I'm,
I'm very optimistic,
you know,
a lot of the most,
I don't know,
a lot of the most informative stuff that
I learn each and every day are from my
boy that is in college right now,
Harry.
Yeah.
And uh,
actually I think he's in charge of,
uh,
his science clubs,
social media.
I forget what it's,
I forget the instagram.
You don't have to look it up,
Jamie,
but I think it's like Simpson Simpson
Chemistry club or something.
But he's every day,
every week he posts different Kim facts,
like chemistry,
facts.
Science is crazy.
If you're someone who doesn't really
study it,
there's a lot of ridiculous information
out there.
You start looking at that and you
realize any of the stuff that we're
talking about,
it's 100% possible.
Well,
there's,
every new innovation builds on potential
new innovations that branch off of them
and they're were always constantly
pushing the curve.
It's like they're not staying stagnant
in any industry.
Like there's nothing where
technologically everybody's stagnant.
Whether it's automobiles,
automobiles,
like they're,
they're getting better and better every
day.
Computers better and better.
Everyday phones,
better and better everyday tvs,
better in bed.
It's just never ending.
It's not there.
They are on this constant state of
innovation and progression that is
really stunning to watch because we're
almost like watching some cascade of
complexity that is reaching some
infinite point.
Did the,
the newest,
latest a htc vives,
these um,
uh,
virtual reality goggles that you put on
there,
just they're letting you know,
hey,
this is the future.
The future's other realities in pill
form.
Other realities that are going to be
able to put your hand on a building.
It's going to send you into another
dimension.
I mean,
these are really real things that are
going to address real matrix.
Really make real matrix within 50 years.
In 50 years.
Do you think it will desensitize a mean?
They say video game.
Well,
back in our day they said music,
right?
Music was what?
Desensitize people,
right?
That's the basis of
now they say video games.
This is right now,
it's,
trump recently said video games are
causing violence,
which is like,
come on man.
I don't know if it's causing violence,
but I would certainly,
I would certainly think that people
desensitized to blood and Gore.
Yeah,
because I mean you're right.
Back when,
back when we were,
well you would have been before me,
but
like,
I don't know,
grand theft auto.
It was a little bit after my time.
Like for me it was mortal Kombat.
Oh yeah.
The adult population couldn't stand
mortal Kombat because you ripped
someone's spine out and held it up in
the air and that was it calling.
Can you talk about that though?
Instead of being desensitized,
aren't they just not sensitive enough
yet because they haven't been exposed to
it?
So like you write the piece of what
you're describing,
a combat lived through Vietnam.
Like they,
they saw all of that
as kids.
You're a hundred percent correct.
Powerful young Jamie.
Yeah.
Good point.
That's a very good,
very good point.
That's a super good point because that's
really exactly what's happening.
You know,
they're not experiencing real violence
and maybe that's the answer.
Maybe it was like the,
a real understanding of what real
violence is,
what would make you more of
real violence.
So the more disconnected we are with
real violence,
the more,
almost as cartoonish expression of
violence as being an alternative for
being bored,
being an alternative,
being like bullied or tortured.
Like instead of something to be avoided.
It's like your,
your last hurrah before you exit this
life.
Like you're,
you've,
you've flipped over the board game,
you've pulled the plug out on the video
game ness and this is what,
like extreme violences that it seems to
be more of that maybe even than
anything.
Definitely could be.
I mean,
you know,
my boy is a,
he's going to school to be a vet
and he's been,
you know,
he's able to,
to look at,
luckily he works for a veterinary clinic
in our town and he's personally been
there for surgeries and he's been there
for several years.
So he's seen a lot of things.
But,
uh,
the doctors were originally telling him,
you know,
hey,
if you feel a little bit sensitive this,
or if you feel like you might pass out,
let us know.
But you know,
Harry has been with me through a big
portion of
his life,
so he's seen one of these things,
seeing things get shot,
and he'd seen things get,
feel dressed,
he's seen things get broken apart and
he's seen things get cooked for the
family.
So he's literally seen all the stages of
really what life is.
It's a port,
you know,
it's living,
it's dying,
and then it's being consumed by what is
living.
So,
you know,
they were a little bit surprised by the
fact that he understood all that.
But I think because he's experienced
that he did understand it.
Oh,
for sure.
I mean,
he's experiencing it in a real life
scenario versus in a video or in a book,
right?
You just,
there's no way to learn life from a
video or a book.
What you can do is get exposed to ideas
that will intrigue you and you want to
have those experiences.
But this is a giant difference.
It's like the difference between
watching porn and having sex,
I literally is right.
I mean that's the perfect example.
Yeah,
it actually is.
It is the perfect example of that.
You have to experience things and until
you do,
you don't know.
And you know,
we're always battling for,
you know,
people take us seriously.
We're always battling for our position
in the social food chain and all that
clouds the way we communicate with each
other too.
I think we just have to get way better
at this and I think we're operating on
some were we're in like this weird snake
shedding of the skin stage.
We're just got to shake off all the
stupid shit that was invented by slave
owners.
All the dumb shit that's been like
involved in our system from the
beginning.
We have to realize like no one knows
what the fuck's going on.
We have to look at everything for what
it really is and forget about the past.
Can we do right now?
What can we do right now?
And do you think it's like a lot of
things in life where you really,
really liked something in,
you almost go too far and then in the
end you think,
okay,
we've gone maybe a little bit too far.
We're going to back things off.
Do you think that's the truth and what
we're doing right now?
Do you think we're almost becoming too
lenient?
And then we're going to get to the point
where like,
you know what,
we have to have some,
some discipline to where I wasn't a
starbucks the other day I thought about
posting it,
but I didn't,
I actually thought about sending it to
you,
but I didn't.
But it was,
it was in a starbucks and it said,
uh,
there was a bathroom that said any sex
and there was a male,
a woman and a guy in a wheelchair.
I'm like,
since when?
Since when is a a person in a
wheelchair,
a sex like,
you know,
it's almost like they're afraid to,
to put something on the door to where
they just make it as broad as possible
and it's like,
you know,
we have to have,
we have to have some lines.
Otherwise it's just nothing but gray.
Well there's not,
here's the thing man.
I think all this is in response to the
idea that men and women are competing
against each other.
I think that's what we've got to cut the
shit.
I think if this idea that like there's a
diff,
like there's no doubt
that you need women
and you need men.
We need humans,
right?
We need each other.
Yup.
So we've got to figure out like why is
everybody so hung up on gender?
Is there an imbalance?
And whatever that imbalance is,
it's got to be corrected,
but it's got to be corrected honorably
and it's got to be corrected.
Honestly.
Like we have to be nice to each other.
All of us,
we like each other.
Girls like boys,
boys like girls.
That's how it's always been.
And any aberrations of that can really
fuck your head up,
but I think they're more aberrations
than they are the norm and I think we
have to figure out how to make those
aberrations lesser and lesser and no
one's concentrating on that.
Instead,
they're concentrating on boys versus
girls and I think that's crazy.
It's like if you only like men,
I can't hang out with you,
dude.
You're going to say some fucked up shit
about women and I'm going to go,
that's my daughter.
That's my sister.
That's my mom.
You can't do that.
Like this idea that like we're on a team
and we're on team dicks and team vaginas
trying to fucking steal our gold.
Like this is stupid.
It's stupid.
We can't do that anymore.
Just like we can't do team white people.
Right.
That's not good either.
It's not good team.
A fucking beige people.
If you all beige people,
all beige people speak Spanish,
get on a team.
Come on.
What are we doing?
It's all the same.
It's whether it's,
whether it's sexual orientation,
whether it's gay,
straight,
whether it's black,
white,
male,
female,
Asian,
Spanish,
Galleon people,
people,
nice people,
interesting people,
different people.
We have to learn that we're in a global
community,
like who really have to figure it out.
And we're closer and closer than we've
ever been before.
But along the way we're going to get
ridiculous shit.
We're going to get like people that are
completely overreacting and all men are
sexist and all men are rapists and all
sex with a penis and vagina is rape.
And there's like,
there's a lot of that going on right
now,
but that's,
those are the echoes of the farthest
reaches of the idea.
And then that idea,
we'll pull back into the middle and then
the general consensus will be
established.
That's what people do.
Did I ever tell you about the time I
went to India?
No,
I did.
I don't think so.
I went to India for just short of a
month coaching.
And uh,
you did tell me this.
Oh,
now I remember.
Yeah,
it's a pretty good story.
But the first part was I wanted to try
to blend in.
I never been to a third,
third large giant man in America,
in America,
you know,
do we take pictures together?
I'm like,
it's like,
it's cute.
I'm like looking up at your armpits so
you are in your giant for a place that
doesn't have giant people.
I told him,
I said I will,
I'll come down and coach,
I'll work for a month.
But I said,
I,
you know,
I was more worried about my safety than
anything.
So I said I'll come down,
but you know,
I really want to,
I want to have a good flight.
You know,
I was going along way and said I want
to,
if I'm on the train,
cause I knew I had about a four hour
train ride.
I said I want first class,
you know,
start to finish.
And I don't want to sound like a Prima
Donna,
but I also knew that I was going to a
third world country.
So asking for first class doesn't
necessarily mean firstclass here.
Um,
so anyway,
firstclass meant that my seats on my
train had,
um,
vinyl covering on there.
So I flew into my airport,
got off the train,
I was trying to blend in,
had some old blue jeans on,
gray shirt,
literally stepped off and it was like
the DJ fricking scratch the record from
like song five to song one.
It was like,
yeah.
And literally every single like a sea of
people that were two feet shorter than
me just literally stopped trains,
stopped everything,
stopped everyone looked at the six and a
half foot dude standing in this Indian
fricking trained train depot.
And uh,
I thought all right,
so I'm to so much for blending in and
went up to the first class,
a train lounge,
which was pretty much the train's loud,
a train lounge that had seats.
Um,
went up there and made friends with the
cockroach that was in the bathroom.
And then I got on the train,
uh,
did about three to four hours on a
train.
Uh,
we stopped a few times cause there were
some cows on the tracks.
You're not allowed to mess with the
cows.
I guess so we had to wait for them to
naturally move off the tracks.
Beep.
There was actually two dead bodies on
our train.
Have I ever told you this?
There are two dead bodies and they put
the dead bodies in the,
on the floor of the aisle between the
people.
So our s our seats had vinyl on there.
The first class,
the non firstclass did not.
I remember at one point I looked back
in,
there was two dead bodies that had
sheets over him.
And then in the far back of the train,
like where the trains connect,
there was actually a,
um,
an Indian guy that was squatting down
pretty much rip and has dong a backwards
so that he could take a leak while the
in between the trains.
Like he opened the door and he was
squatting down letting one rip between
the trains.
And uh,
yeah,
I was sitting there thinking,
Oh man,
I've got 20 days left here.
But in saying that,
once I got to where I was,
um,
they were probably the best students
I've ever had because they were the most
disciplined.
Every one of those students wanted to
get out of that lifestyle and they saw
that being a national level shooter was
going to get them out of that lifestyle.
So every single thing I taught them,
they took it to a level that was far
beyond what most people here would ever,
ever,
ever do.
Did they build as well?
Did they build beaus they teach them how
to do all that stuff to their peeps?
Some of their,
some of the people on their national
team,
their peep site,
which is the small little circle that's
in your bow string that allows you to
kind of,
it's almost like,
if you can imagine a rifle he ever rear
sight and a front sight.
So the peep side is in your string.
It's a circle and it's your rear sight
and then you align it with the front
sight.
There's was,
theirs was made out of wood.
They would have a stick with a hole
drilled in it and they would put that in
their string.
Wow.
So imagine someone like that in your,
they're giving him instruction and every
single thing you tell them to do,
they'll do it to the 10th degree because
they want out.
I mean,
it was extreme motivation.
I felt like everything that I was doing
from a training point of view was
inadequate to what they were doing.
The only difference was they didn't have
the education that we had.
They were disconnected.
I remember,
um,
I would actually have to go to an
Internet cafe and I'd have to pay for
five minutes of Internet,
like dial up internet to call Sharon.
So,
I mean,
you look at people that are like that,
they want it at a level that's so far
beyond what a lot of,
I mean,
we're just floating in the gravy over
here.
I mean,
it's,
it's true.
It's true.
It's totally true.
Yeah.
You look at some of the,
some of the people I've,
um,
I was a keynote speaker at an,
uh,
an international coaching convention in
Brazil before the Olympics there.
And you go down there and you realize
some of these people are,
they want it way more than the people
that have it easy and the,
and that was the case though,
right?
Yeah.
That's the case.
That's the people that are hungry are
the ones that are really struggling to
make it.
And that's what gets tough is,
you know,
learning to stay on top.
Um,
when you have it easy,
when there's people that are literally
investing every single day and getting
to that point.
Yeah.
It's,
that's the fuel,
right?
Those,
that's one of the weird things is very
few people who grow up with like some
crazy inheritance plan and millions
dollars in the bank as well.
That's a bond problem.
I think it's a giant prior,
I think it's a big problem.
It's a giant problem with those people.
Anybody that grows up in that scenario
where you are never really taught the
value of accomplishing things and then
it's,
it's not just about securing your fate,
it's also about managing your
consciousness and accomplishing things
is good for you and you can't think it's
not.
You have to just accept it and learn it
and think of it as a sort of a growing
experience.
And if you don't do that,
you're not going to grow.
And if you don't grow,
you're going to be fucked.
You're going to be fucked.
Whether you're rich or you're poor,
it's your missing the thing.
The thing is now how many Zeros and ones
you collect.
That's not the thing.
The thing is like how well do you feel
while you're going through it?
And if you're doing it wrong,
you've got to figure out what it is.
Well,
obviously having $1 million in the bank
is not doing it right.
If the dude's still taking pills and
super depressed,
it's not the money.
Right?
So what is it?
What's the thing in you?
And I have both met a lot of people in
that category.
I think everybody you talk to on the,
everybody that's goes through,
it's hard.
Life is hard.
There's a lot of people that have
fallen,
fallen into that category,
and it could have been me.
It easily could've.
I had different scenarios,
different circumstances,
different,
you know,
different neighborhood.
I grew up.
In any case,
it can go wrong.
You,
you,
you can go down the dark road and all of
a sudden you're fucked.
That's,
that's the case for all of us.
Do you feel like,
I feel,
you know,
a lot of people look at me as an archer.
I've been,
uh,
made a very,
very good career.
I couldn't possibly have made it better.
I don't think for B for shooting a bow
for living.
I don't think I could have made it
better.
And there's definitely archers that are
better than me.
I never claimed to be the best.
I just claim to be the one that is
willing to share the most.
I don't claim that I have the most
natural title talent.
I just feel like I,
I'm willing to share the most,
but I dunno.
I also feel like feel like there's this,
I don't know,
this part of me that feels like if I
didn't,
even though I don't have necessarily
talent,
the fact that I am willing to share it,
I think it takes it to a different level
because I don't know if I've ever shared
this with you.
Do you know about my past as a kid?
Yeah.
You,
you told me a lot of different things
about you burn your house down
accidentally.
I did.
Okay.
Yeah.
So a big,
a big part of why I actually joined
sports to begin with because originally
I was a skater.
I like to skate and um,
you know,
I wasn't really into organized sports.
And the craziest thing is you abandoning
football.
Yeah.
For archery.
Well,
but before that,
the reason I got into football's because
my dad was such a great athlete that,
you know,
I played with matches and took it too
far,
ended up burning my house down,
literally had nothing.
My mom was in Puerto Rico on a business
trip.
My Dad was at work,
burned her house.
So the ground.
Um,
I remember being there when my family
was sifting through ashes,
literally trying to find something to
salvage from our history as a family.
Um,
and my dad was such a stellar athlete
that I felt like the only thing I could
do to really make him proud of me at
that point was become a good athlete.
So I focus on becoming a good athlete.
And that was my drive was because it
wasn't because I really liked it.
It was because of the fee.
It was because of guilt.
It was because I really felt like the
only thing I could do to make my dad who
was,
um,
a military guy,
someone who had definitely earned a
street creds.
I felt like the only thing I could do
was become this great athlete,
which he was in order to earn his
respect.
And Kennedy did that in order to make up
for the fact that,
you know,
I had this one moment as an adolescent
where I literally burn down every single
thing our family ever had.
Holy Shit,
man.
I mean,
imagine going.
Imagine,
right now when we're done with this
podcast,
you get a call and you realize your
house was on fire and
it's different now because we have
phones.
But imagine we don't have phones.
Every single picture you have of your
family,
you know every single one is gone.
Every,
you know,
every single thing that maybe someone's
signed for you and the UFC has gone
every single year.
Black belt that you got from Eddie is
burn.
It's gone.
Like that's gone.
Every single thing from right now into
till you were born is gone.
That's what my parents loss and it was
because of me.
So you know what man,
they did lose you.
I think ultimately the difference
between you making a mistake of burn the
house down,
which is horrific.
Are you dying?
Yup.
That's the big difference.
Like everything worked out.
Look,
hey you are,
everything's great.
Well,
and that's,
that's what was great about my dad was
the fact that once that moment happened,
my mom and my dad have never ever
brought that up.
They've never hold that.
They've never held that over me.
It's been me from the outside looking in
thinking they've never mentioned this
because they know that I feel so bad
about it,
but me being competitive as a,
as an athlete was because I wanted to
make my dad proud from that aspect and
literally that competitive drive as a
football player and track or whatever
else that,
that fed the archery side.
Because when I went to my archery
tournament for the first time and I
sucked at it,
I was naturally competitive and really
wanted to be better at it.
Now that wasn't because of the fire,
but that was just because of really
because of a principle that competitive
sports put in me,
you know?
So it,
it's crazy how,
uh,
it's crazy how it all these little
pieces build character.
But you know,
that's why,
um,
several weeks ago there was a really big
archery tournament and I actually got
wind,
which I'm not,
I'm not big on kind of feeding in or
buying into negativity at all.
But there was some,
some negativity that I heard from other
shooters that are shooting now and
shooting currently saying,
you know,
why is this guy,
why is this guy popular?
Why is it a successful?
He's not even shooting right now.
He's not even competing.
And you know,
yeah.
Dirty Green Monster and V.
Yeah,
exactly.
It is John Dudley get all the,
yeah.
And,
and I,
I've been pretty,
uh,
are you going to do gollum again?
He did that on the last podcast.
That's not calling.
It's pretty good though.
Um,
I dunno.
I feel like,
I feel like these people that,
that feed on the negativity,
they don't understand that all these
little things that have happened or
building blocks and I want to use it as
motivation to the people out there.
Not everyone has a perfect picture,
you know,
people see where maybe you and I are
now,
but they don't realize.
We also had huge hurdles before we got
here.
And it's how you address those,
you know,
and how you take adversity.
That's really who defines you and it's a
really,
really good opportunity for you to,
to set a precedence of I had hardship,
I made over it.
And you know,
you can become inspiration for people by
having that obstacle and then overcoming
it.
Yeah.
Well I think that's the big point is
that we all learned from each other.
Now,
most certainly learned from you telling
me about your struggles as well as I
have from most of my friends that tell
me about their struggles or things that
I've read about or things that I've seen
in documentaries or things we learn from
each other.
And you,
you get,
uh,
we're,
I think we're all accumulating data as
far as like how the world works,
what's the best way to behave and what's
the best way to live.
And we're all in the middle of
accumulating all this data.
We're all taking it and inform each
other and we've gotta be open to it.
You know,
you've got to be open to taking it from
even like,
although it seems kind of corny
sometimes,
like I will read some shit by the rock
or I will watch a Kevin Hart instagram
video and I get fucking fired up.
I'm like,
I'm going to go do this man and mean if
it's not jocko saying good or if it's
not just dope.
Or when I think about that David Goggins
podcasts,
I did very good dude.
I think about Goggins and my Jesus
Christ.
Yeah.
I just,
I can't even understand that kind of
mental intensity.
That'd be just,
he was freaking me out,
man,
who's freaking me out and the most
impressive way,
like,
I just like,
I'm like,
he was 100% that goes 100% seriously
ready to die,
uh,
on a foot race.
He's ready to die.
100% he's looking at,
he's not lying at all,
was not no party.
He's taking it to the dark lands.
He's going to take you to the dark
lands.
Will you follow?
Will you follow him to the dark lands
gam those ceos and does the same?
He took us to the dark land with
Tequila,
the Tequila universe.
Well,
he'll do it with everything.
He's an animal,
but,
but those,
those people and they expresses itself
differently in all these different
exceptional people.
Like Jocko is different than Tim.
Tim Kennedy.
Ted Kennedy is different than Andy
there.
There were all different but also all
incredibly exceptional.
But there's something that they give
off.
I like that though.
When you talked about the exception
among the accent.
Yeah,
that's what,
um,
I think,
he'd called it David Goggins called it
uncommon amongst uncommon people.
That's true.
Yeah.
That is very,
very true.
That's the Colby Bryan and killing
people right there.
They just,
I mean,
I read this thing about Kobe Bryant the
other day.
I was just reading,
oh,
I don't know anything about basketball.
Okay.
And I always refer to Jamie,
but anything in basketball,
I have zero idea.
I don't know how long it takes,
can take a day.
How many corridors?
I have no idea.
I would imagine if you say quarters,
I'd say there's four of them.
Can you see how many periods?
I don't know how many.
Half Times,
but it was reading all this stuff about
his high school coach saying that they
would,
they would get there and he would be
shooting baskets in the dark because
they hadn't even turned the lights on
yet.
He'd be there an hour or two hours
before everybody that he would show up
at these practices.
Everybody would be at breakfast and he
would show up with ice on his knees and
he was fully sweated out.
Like he just done three hours of work
and out before anybody did anything.
There's,
there's people like that man,
and you can hate on them.
You can hate on them.
You could decide that this not worth it,
but you got to,
the best thing you can do is acknowledge
that they're doing something that makes
you feel funny.
Yep.
And that makes you feel funny,
is your sense of understanding who you
are.
It's testing,
testing how you feel about yourself.
It's testing how you feel about your
place in the universe is testing it.
You don't want to know that there's some
crazy Koby Bryant motherfucker getting
up at four in the morning,
you know,
doing dead lifts like Shit,
I want to sleep,
but I also want to be number one bro.
Yup.
Former Lakers player and head coach
Byron Scott said he wants found an 18
year old bryant shooting in a dark gm
two hours before practice.
I used to do that,
but it's throwing footballs,
throwing footballs into a,
it was actually into the laundry
baskets.
It's not uncommon,
man.
It's not uncommon if you,
if you really want to agreed.
I mean,
you know,
my sleeping hours are super,
super regular.
There's times where I feel like
practicing or a lot of times you'll
probably get up in the morning and I've
already built your bow and I built a
four or five in the morning because two
people that are the exceptional among
their field,
they can't sleep if they know that they
have to do something.
What is,
what are we looking at something because
as you guys are talking about this,
he just tore his Achilles.
This is probably one of those last
things he did.
He tore his Achilles led in order.
This is like a rule in the game.
He had to shoot.
His free throws is,
it's a weird stipulation.
So he's walking back out with no
Achilles and he did does this.
It was pretty,
pretty impressive.
Barely walk man.
Holy Shit.
No crying or nothing.
But yeah,
it's really fucked up.
That's how you have to be.
If you want to be a winner,
there's just no way around it.
You know,
Swish hollow.
That's why I get the money.
Look at my mansion at that point.
It's just subconscious taken over.
Anybody that doesn't think that someone
like coby Bryant doesn't deserve mansion
and all the money has just done,
does not understand what he just did.
Two swishes in a row with no Achilles.
Just shut the fuck up.
I don't know shit about basketball.
I know.
That was amazing.
I've been pretty,
I've actually been pretty stuck on this
subject in the last few weeks.
Um,
I hardly ever,
ever,
ever look at negativity.
I mean,
I really don't read it,
don't look at it.
But,
um,
there was a really big archery
tournament,
uh,
about a month ago and there were some
other pros that had made some comments
about me just saying,
you know,
how has John Dudley on a gre podcasts,
he's not even competing,
he's not doing anything.
And you know,
people wanted to know how I felt about
that.
And I said,
the reality is there's several archer's
out there that have 10 times the talent
in me.
No question.
I'm not saying that I have that,
but what really is shitty about that
situation is when someone has 10 times
more talent in me and they do a 10th as
much,
to me that's a big problem.
So you think there's a lot of people out
there that are not realizing their full
potential.
So because of that,
they're critical of other people because
maybe even they're looking at their own
self and they,
they feel like they're not,
I don't know.
I think,
I think they're looking at the problem
is because the people do do that,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
You limit yourself when you are not
looking at what you're doing,
when you're so occupied on what someone
else is doing,
you limit what your true talent is.
So is that my problem?
Is it my problem that you have 10 times
the talent in me,
but I'm doing 10 times more with it?
Is that,
is that my problem as a big numbers?
Okay,
let's say two times.
Okay.
Let's say,
let's say you have twice a town
naturally have more,
but you're doing less,
right?
Yeah.
I know what you're saying.
I just feel like there's a lot of people
doing that,
but yeah,
there's,
I think,
I actually think the majority,
I think the people that are standouts
are people that don't have the natural,
true talent.
I think Jon Jones is a perfect example.
If he was able to literally 100%
maximizes talent,
how good could he be?
The problem is he's the one that has 10
times the talent,
but he's screwing it up and there's guys
that have half the talent that are
bigger stars because they're actually
doing it the right way and they're
maximize.
They're almost,
they're almost doubling their potential
because they're working at it in the
right fashion versus someone that has
the true talent isn't really maximizing
their talent.
Hmm.
I know he's saying,
yeah,
but I think here's a good sign.
He's a really good sign.
This is an easy way to decipher it.
When you see someone complaining about
someone else's success,
anytime you see that,
anytime you see someone complaining
about someone else's success and
possibly equate again to like some
injustice in the world because they
don't have equal success,
the person's making a mistake.
They're making mistake and even the way
they're thinking,
if you criticize something because you
just think it's bad,
well that's certainly your prerogative,
right?
I mean if you just,
if it's,
especially if it's an art form or if
it's something someone created,
that's one thing,
but if you're upset that someone
success,
that doesn't make any sense.
Well,
they want it to be successful.
They did the thing that it took to be
successful.
They became successful.
And what's your point?
You don't have a point.
Your point is born a mood.
It's the little little kids version of
would me,
what about me?
Well,
I,
it's not fair.
It's not fair that some people are born
billionaires.
It's not fair.
It's not fair that some people are born
with birth defects where they don't have
feet.
It's not fair that some people,
their their,
their fucking brain doesn't work as well
as yours.
There's a lot of shit.
It's not fair.
Look at what you got.
You're doing well and you're worried
about someone else's doing better.
Why not just look at them?
Why not just look at them and go,
well,
what does that guy do in different,
what is she doing different than me?
How come she's so much more successful?
How did he figure out how to do that and
look at it that way?
Don't look at it like you're angry at
those people.
That shit is wasted.
It doesn't do you any good.
It does zero good for anybody involved.
Not You,
not the person,
your person.
You're trying to figure out why that was
fucking good.
Good.
That shit is just bad for you.
It's bad for everybody.
It's bad for the person thinking
negatively.
It's bad for everybody around them.
The best way to do is like,
Huh?
Like even if you not even hateful about
it,
like,
like here's a good example.
Like if a movie is fucking giant in the
box office,
you're like,
wow,
I thought it sucked.
I didn't like it or whatever.
But if you freak out hose full move with
Jumanji
fucked shit.
Me Bro.
Jumanji that fucking piece of shit in
our people get crazy.
They get crazy that I made $800 million
for fucking Jumanji can't.
It's not good for you man.
You gotta to let that go.
Don't worry about Jumanji worry about
yourself.
She [inaudible] it's pretty good.
It's hard twice kids,
man.
I haven't seen it yet.
It's pretty good.
I thought it was very good.
It's really well done.
It's Kevin Hart and the rock together.
You can't mess Jack Black and one of the
best performances and years and whoever
was the hot redhead check.
She was great too though.
I think Jack Black was getting shame.
He's got one of those Farrah Fawcett
poster is going to check.
I just look something up weird.
It's not,
it's sort of related.
The Jurassic world.
Did you see that movie when it came out
a couple of years ago?
Yeah.
It's the number three all time grossing.
Thank God.
Are you kidding me?
Hey,
fuck the godfather.
Chris Pratt.
If you want archery lessons,
legitimately does.
I bet he does legitimate.
You know,
did you see that an instagram post that
he put up of is a sheep or a lamb that
he killed?
He had a pet lamb put a bolt to its head
and you know,
and chopped it all up and people freak
the fuck out though.
Like this is our food.
He didn't see it.
Dude.
Chris Pratt,
Scott some balls.
I saw him post a picture of a rub in on
a tree.
Oh,
he hunts and he said,
uh,
said something about trolls.
Yo,
what's up Chris?
Right here.
Now the 2018.
What's that?
This is like a rap rapping that sounded
like this.
The new album.
No.
Pratt rap.
He um,
he does though.
Go is,
uh,
that's not it.
There's a video where he shows the lamb
that he's actually taken apart.
This is the snow in the video.
It says it.
Okay.
When I ate it all.
Well,
no.
What I meant is there photographs.
She's actually photographs of the
butchered lamb and people lost their
fucking Shit,
man.
That's,
that's not it.
It's um,
there's actually like photographs of the
meat and like there's a roast in the
roast is there.
It is,
right.
The one in the middle.
Yeah.
And this one gets a legitimate,
I don't know if that's necessarily land.
They came from his,
I'm assuming it honestly sounds like it
says,
look at all this glorious food.
We will eat off him for a month.
His wools becoming yarn as we speak.
He lived a very good life.
He was groomed and shorn.
His hooves medicated.
Why he wormed and no antibiotics
necessary.
Surrounded by laughing and loving
humans,
including children to whom they provided
such joy nozzle,
pat and loved every day.
No stressful travel to his final
destination.
Trauma free just to touch of a u s d a
certified wan to his head and he goes to
sleep.
The other sheep don't even notice.
It's unplugging
your TV.
Then Waka Waka he's got a butcher name.
Wacom,
my Bush or Waka Flocka side job then
blankets or wrapper.
It is definitely,
you're so white walk.
My butcher were magic.
He's definitely right now the meat is
for friends,
family and gifts.
Soon though it may be available to my
followers as we test recipes and opened
up to market.
Oh my God,
he's got a murder animals for a living.
I got to get some things dialed in
first,
including murder,
murder of sheep.
Just kidding.
Like he is.
I eat meat,
but that's a glorious how get the balls
in this guy.
When has a a list actor ever considered
opening?
I agree.
A meat shop and showed a photo on his
instagram of the honest procurement of
meat in an honest way.
Did you see that post I made today?
No.
What?
Which one?
My,
I have my airplane mode on so I can't
post it.
But I think,
um,
I made a post,
uh,
it was a google search that I did.
There was 21 independent,
um,
legitimate scientists that found that if
you ate 50 grams of processed meat per
day,
your chance of cancer was 18% higher.
Holy Shit.
Just think of that number now is at
night nitrites.
What is it?
What are the,
what are they thinking?
It's causing that.
Yeah.
That part wasn't clearly defined,
but I would definitely think it was
preserved based,
but
they don't really know though.
Right.
They know it's processed meat.
It's really dangerous.
Yeah.
They don't know what it is exactly.
That's what right.
Awesome about how you and I hunt.
I posted it specifically to actually
some access backstraps from Hawaii last
year.
Um,
because I think,
I think it's maybe ignorant for people
to automatically make a post saying,
you know,
you're a killer just because you post a
picture of,
you know,
free range,
organic meat that you decided to choose
a touch.
Um,
look at it.
I know what you're saying,
but you got to look at it from their
perspective.
I do.
Even if they're not right,
and there's no right here.
The thing is there's there,
right,
and you're right,
it's everybody's right.
It's this really what's fucked up about
it.
Like an animal does have to die.
You know it.
That is a fact.
And that does bother people,
including you and me when it happens.
And people don't realize that.
But that is true.
They don't.
But the,
the understanding at the end of the day
is that this is the cycle of life and
this is what life is really all about.
So they're right in your right,
but this whole,
this expression of outrage,
like you should be expressing that at
Burger King.
You should be,
and not Burger King,
just,
you know,
I'm not singling them out.
Anybody that has fast food,
which I've eaten many times.
If you want to live in a society of 20
million people,
you're going to have to live in a place
most likely with this model where you've
got in and out Burger.
And I like in and out Burger.
I like them.
They taste good,
but go ahead.
We went there in Vegas,
they've got damn good,
right?
It's hard to beat,
so I don't necessarily hate those
things,
but you have to understand what all this
really is.
You know?
It's the whole thing is crazy.
You're here for a very short period of
time,
as are these animals.
All of us are trying to stay alive.
All of us are freaking out.
One of the things get eaten and we're
all just going like,
well,
I just want to be the best version of
me.
I can be your right hand there,
right?
They just,
they haven't experienced what they,
they have decided that an animal should
not die.
There's no way an animal should die so
that they can live,
and if they can live that way,
that's their choice.
They're welcome to that choice.
They just don't understand the merit of
your choice.
The merit of your choice is just
diametrically opposed to what they think
should be and should not be a thing a
person does.
You shouldn't be a person that kills
animals,
but when you're engulfed in that world,
when you're living in the woods,
when you're,
when you're going through these seven,
eight,
nine,
10 day hunts,
you give us understanding of what this
world around these things.
It really is.
It's this crazy,
beautiful,
complex interaction between Predator and
prey and it's been going on since life
was here.
Yeah.
Just what it is and what you're doing as
a hunter is just figuring out with your
soft bitch ass skin and you're,
you're fucking shaky knees,
bad ankles weasely yourself into a
position where you can jump into the
food chain with wolves around that
fucking conversation that we had about
wolves.
Did that change people's understanding
of what a wolf is when on the first time
you came on the podcast,
you talked about how the wolves to try
and take your
away from you too.
That's a crazy story.
Yeah.
I mean,
there are my all time favorite stories.
Yeah.
There at camp,
I mean,
there's an interaction going on Predator
and prey.
This is happening.
Your name.
It's not like it's established and it's
written in stone.
Every level of the food chain is being
competitive with the next.
Yeah.
It's not like it is a very clear cut
concrete step to where every step is
clear.
Humans are here,
wolves are here,
grizzlies are here,
access deer here.
Turkeys are here and I would,
I would inject one other thing.
Cwd Yup.
Chronic wasting diseases.
Kill study biology comes into this
thing.
Diseases is
are creeping in and killing deer left
and right and a lot of people feel like
these diseases were created by people
farming those deal.
It was dear taking them out of the wild
environments and letting them like eat
off
the same food and constantly exchange
bacteria with each other and that's what
created this thing.
I've,
I've told people metro times that I feel
like mother nature is a form of Karma.
I think Mother Nature will take care of
herself.
I think as things below that level,
try to occupy their own status.
I think that's the balance.
That's a check that's in process.
I think Mother Nature,
naturally,
I think if you decide I'm not going to
shoot any turkeys,
I'm going to just let these turkeys go
as wild as they can.
I think all sudden mother nature comes
in and says,
uh,
I'm going to throw a little trump card
in here called black heads disease.
This is going to kill every freaking
Turkey in your area and I'm going to
regulate this
according fasting.
Does that always happens?
Yeah.
When animals get over it and that's one
of the things and it's being concerned
about Hawaii,
right?
Disease.
Yup.
And then you look at a white tail and
areas where maybe there's been,
you know,
I guess quote Unquote Trophy Hunters to
where they've not really,
um,
I guess regulated the population of
Whitetail deer to point where,
you know,
they're trying to grow trophy hunting.
So to me to try and grow a deer with
large animals,
larger antlers.
So there may be shooting less numbers
and then all of a sudden here comes this
little thing called Ehd,
which kills every whitetail.
It goes to drink water.
I don't know it,
it is chronic wasting disease.
EAC is different.
It's an image that actually lives in the
mud.
I'm on the receiving water line on a
pond.
So as a,
you know,
as a whitetail deer would go into
actually drink,
uh,
this mitch fly lives in the,
in the soil on the re the receding
waterline,
and it would go into the nostril of the
deer and then literally within 48 hours,
that deer's debt,
if it,
if it gets that,
that virus,
look at the name of it.
Epic Zoo,
epizootic hemorrhagic disease and you
know,
so it's like an ebola type disease.
I think a bowl is that Ebola hemalogic
disease.
Not,
didn't have to pee so hard.
Me Too.
I've never had a pee more of my life.
This is awesome.
We've had a,
I did I pee before the trial.
There's a different suit.
Wolves and coyotes.
I saw that picture.
It's an amazing picture.
Somebody's got to picture between this
majestic black wolf with fucking white
glowing eyes that both looks amazing.
Like I'm out to coyote is like,
fuck all this.
We've got to get away from that thing,
man,
that is so heavy.
Go from Ehd to two coyotes running from
a black wool.
How do we concentrate on the,
what's that set
it up.
Um,
did you think you guys could talk for a
few minutes?
Where Ip,
go for it.
Keep it together.
Yeah.
Talk about sports.
Sports.
All right,
Jamie.
Well,
yeah,
I mean is this is the first official
podcast where Rogan's had to actually
maybe like the second or third time and
a second time?
Yes.
It's dumped back on podcast.
The flex that,
yep.
Uh,
no,
this is pretty,
pretty epic right here to make Rogan
actually go.
That means he's consumed more than he's
talked.
That's pretty powerful.
That happens from time to time.
I know.
I like that sweatshirt.
Jamie's actually told me earlier,
he's trying to make a profession out of
video gaming,
which I would know about refreshing,
but a,
I stream from time to time on twitch,
which is an interesting thing that you
said your son does it a little bit or he
looks at it.
Yeah.
Well,
I used to play quite a bit.
Our,
uh,
we had two accounts.
One was death by Dudley on playstation.
And,
uh,
the other one was bald,
hairless Yeti.
He playing with them like you guys play
at times?
We did.
Yeah.
We were big modern warfare guys.
Um,
we really liked that and actually I met,
um,
I met several cool dudes during that,
during that,
uh,
online play.
I always,
you know,
honestly I felt like if I was a
competitive archer and I would have been
online prior to my competition,
I feel like I almost could have helped
some of my performance anxiety when it
comes to competition because there's so
many.
You get so like into beating the guy
that you're going against that it's,
you can almost freak out and you don't
do things according to a systematic
method,
which is really all a video game is,
is it's if you follow the systematic
method,
you can overcome the alley algorithm.
Right.
For sure.
Um,
but
here it goes.
That was rough.
How was full of those?
Um,
I got to go now.
Do you,
go ahead.
Go ahead norris.
What are you going to talk about?
Whatever you talked about.
I'm going to,
let's,
let's hear this so hard.
That was crazy.
I was talking about her.
I talked about my two online video
gaming accounts with,
with my little dude,
Harry.
One was death by Dudley and the other
one was bald.
Hairless.
She,
Eddie,
what do you play?
Mainly a modern warfare stuff.
Oh yeah.
Anything that you kill someone.
Sadly enough.
Go get you your and on me and I'm young.
Jane will talk about the implications to
that.
Let's hear about this.
What is this?
What is it about these?
I have three coffees.
That's not good.
That's a lot of caffeine.
Thank God you've got that whiskey.
That's dumb.
It down balances.
Perfect.
You'd be talking to how to control
it was one of the drunk or podcasts.
One of them.
Right,
but there's something fun about getting
together with a really good friend.
Just getting lit up.
Smoke a little weed,
drink a little whiskey.
It's have a good time.
Just have a good time.
Today's been a good time.
That guy's a good guy.
John Dudley's a fucking good man.
I love that guy.
He's fun and he's also,
I'm a master at something that's very
difficult to do.
He's a master,
not just at like executing archery,
but instructing it,
teaching people.
It's a fascinating thing that archery
man,
to me it's super important and I think
that everybody goes to these like things
where like what's important to them,
like to you might be a guitar amp,
you know,
might be a certain drums,
a drum sticks.
It might be whatever the fuck you're
into,
you know that might be important to you.
But archery I think is one of those
things that most people miss.
You just don't get a chance at it.
You're like,
God,
that looks good.
That looks like it'd be fun,
but you don't know where to go.
And you never do it like by far most
people.
But once you do do it,
you realize like,
oh,
I can learn about life through this
weird thing.
I'm pulling that string back and I'm
launching a pointed stick at a target
and I'm learning about myself.
Like what I'm learning about how I deal
with situations where I have to execute
correctly under pressure.
Even if it's just a minor pressure of
hitting a target or the major pressure
of hitting an animal.
He learned to that shit.
Jamie,
what are you showing me?
There's this game.
I feel like we've,
I showed this to you awhile ago,
but this is called the hunter call of
the wild.
Should we tell people archery part of
it?
Should we tell,
oh damn.
It's a compound bow it.
Who's got a real bow?
Yeah.
Why has he goes sideways like he's
Gangsta?
I'd probably say you can see,
I bet even once you pull it up to aim,
he better,
so I'm hoping I can get you better pull
it back.
Oh yeah.
He goes,
wow,
that's legit.
Look at this John Dudley,
this gundam archery video game
guys pulling back a bow and looking
through a site like you would like a
real compound bow site.
That's amazing
with the whisker biscuit,
powerful whisker biscuit and then you go
home.
A lot of people still rocket.
A lot of people still rock the bus
about,
I wish the biscuit was in fallible.
I wish it was.
The way to go.
Seems so easy.
I just hate the name.
Yes.
Your biscuit.
Yeah.
I mean I hate it but it's definitely
provocative.
People don't know what we're talking
about.
It's the Arrow go.
Some people definitely do.
Most people don't.
Most people listen to this podcast,
probably don't.
It's a type of archery rest where that
Arrow sits.
It's very controversial.
This is how geeky archery is.
Should you have some fine mesh that's
sort of cradles the Arrow and that
fledglings will pass through that five
mesh possibly knocking down how many
feet per second?
Five.
I'm five feet paws.
Three.
Five scientific.
I don't do that so we'll be stuck in an
hour so we'll be real conservative and
say three,
three feet a second,
which is pretty probably knocks off more
than that but some people like it
because of its simplicity.
There it is.
That's a whisker biscuit and the
fletching is a pass through.
Those fine fibers slow down a little bit
but not too much.
That's literally like training wheels
for your Arrow with John Dudley believes
in is like this crazy drop away type
thing where they have an arrow rest that
drops down.
He makes his own era.
Yep.
Knock on Arrow rest.
[inaudible] it's,
it is the knock on elevates the shit.
Jason.
It's a,
it's a subject I want to talk to you
about.
Never talk to you about this ever.
Oh,
so no.
A bunch of my u s team members,
they're going to shoot me in the face
for tough talking about this because in
the face,
yeah,
literally in the face because one thing
that was an ongoing thing for when I was
on the u s team,
we,
there was this thing that went on about
how long we could go at a tournament
before we talked about this particular
person.
So during my time on the teams,
we actually had a person that was,
um,
she claimed to have a medical disorder
or she didn't actually claim to have it,
but supposedly it happens.
But she claimed to have a disorder where
she had attachment to items.
This girl that was on my team actually
ended up marrying the Eiffel Tower.
I'm serious.
I'm not kidding.
She had an attachment to
a love interest that she actually filed
some claims against.
Supposedly filed some claims against a
boat company that this boat company
actually had a rubber laminate on the
limbs of the bow and
there she is.
Mary's I feel cow.
Is that her?
Wow.
She married a Harris is famous monument.
I wrote a mini buses with,
with her.
Oh my God.
A former soldier who lives in San
Francisco.
She has been in love with the objects
before.
Her first infatuation was with Lance,
a bow that helped her become a
worldclass archer.
She is fond of the Berlin Wall and she
claims to have a physical relationship
with a piece of fence.
She keeps it a bedroom.
What in the fuck?
Why I doing?
What are we doing people,
we can't.
We can't do this.
We've gotten too crazy.
We got to pull back.
Here's the thing,
Mary.
A fucking bridge.
This pitch married a bridge.
She married a Brooklyn Grit near the
Eiffel Tower.
This bitch is marrying a bridge though.
Just kissing.
She's kissing bridges
public object.
But what the fuck does she just say?
Love of the public object.
Crank that up.
I want to hear this crazy lady.
I feel very,
very blessed to have a piece of my sweet
Golden Gate Bridge.
Oh,
Jesus stopped.
I give up.
I'm out.
I hung in there as long as I could with
the bridge.
Hey
Dad,
wait,
wait.
In the middle of all this,
there's a lot of people like me that
have shot tens and tens and tens of
thousands of arrows trying to win a
medal for the country.
But that's different.
You're chasing an accomplishment.
You're not fucking a bridge.
The ladies trying to fuck.
Meanwhile,
she's on our team bus.
She literally,
she slept with her bow one night at an,
at an event and then got an infection
from the silicone on the limbs and the
rest of the team had to deal with this
problem.
Um,
when you say infection,
I don't know where the infection was,
but I would have met Elle.
Oh No.
I want to have on the bottom and a step
away from it.
Mike Olsen,
but hey,
how good was she as an rj?
Jamie?
This is pretty rare.
He's actually like
son of a bitch.
Um,
how good was,
she has an archer.
She must have been very good.
She was on a team,
right?
Oh,
putting the hat on the bow.
Not a good time actually look like pot
holder,
but she must have been like a worldclass
archer.
Right?
Don't do it.
Don't do it to me.
John does.
I would say
decent.
Good Archer.
Dangerous,
decent.
Here's,
here's the thing.
Okay,
so she married the Eiffel Tower.
How'd that work out?
I think she's still married to it.
Friends.
People were pissed.
This is true.
This is 100% true.
French people are pissed because
American just goes over there,
gets his fiance visa,
marries a tower.
Right.
So now we got to dual citizenship.
Meanwhile she's got this thing for the
Berlin Wall.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well the Berlin Wall was a flirt first
of all.
So what Berlin Wall is always like being
real and
giving you this extra long hugs.
The Berlin Wall.
Fucking asked for it.
Jamie cannot.
Of course she's,
she's in love with the Berlin Wall hose.
Dot.
How about you?
Gotta married.
She's married to Eiffel though.
So here's the deal.
Listen to this.
I want Joe to listen to this.
I just randomly picked a spot.
Her last name is eiffel though.
She literally took the legal name and
her name is her name.
Originally it was Islah bree and I had
to travel with her,
but now it's Iowa.
I uh,
eyeful Jamie,
I have to send you something that,
uh,
someone sent me today that I sent to
Brian Cowen.
I'm going to send you it in two seconds.
Um,
who did that think about France moves to
see,
just so you could probably Google it.
France moves,
it's on NPR,
so it's legit.
France moves to make 15 the lead legal
age of consent for sex.
And it's because a bunch of dudes got in
trouble for having sex with 11 year
olds.
What?
Yeah,
we were talking about Roman or not.
I'll leave that.
France moves to make age 15,
the legal age of consent for sex.
Like,
whoa.
There's a,
there's parts of the world that are just
not where we are right now.
Nope.
They're just not,
you don't look at that like you got to
who was saying this?
Who's saying 15?
Like woody,
what you 15 for what an 80 year old,
an 80 year old can fuck a 15 year old.
Is that what you just said?
I'll kill you.
I will fucking kill you.
Hearing guns.
As long as violence,
coercion,
threat or surprise is not proven.
Sexual intercourse with a minor,
even one under 15 is considered.
And I don't know what that means.
Uh,
which is an infraction and not a crime.
It says,
uh,
on tench attention,
sexuality,
which is an infraction and not a crime.
I don't mean come on,
I will put a try pan right through that
guy's face.
Yeah.
They're not even blink.
This is a correction necessary.
You have a,
a cultural issue that's a cultural
issue.
Correction necessary.
No,
you can't fuck 10 year olds.
If anyone has a problem with,
with guys that are,
I can guess,
but that's a hunter's like idiots like
this.
That's terrifying.
That is terrible.
But I think terrifying.
I think this is what happens with
people,
man.
I think people get caught up in whatever
the other people around them are doing
and this is weird mob mentality method.
That's how was the craziest thing I've
seen all day long.
I mean that's ridiculous today,
2018 March,
2018 while we're talking,
this is on the news as of happening
right now in Europe to go,
Whoa,
let's make you to make it illegal to
fuck 14 year olds.
Like what?
You don't have that already on the
books.
Okay,
you could fucking nine year old over
there.
Right?
How old are they have to be?
Is there an age limit at all or is it
just,
oh,
he fucked it.
Bibby module module or sorry,
mercy.
Okay.
That maybe,
is there a year it should make your
stomach turn?
It does,
but here's the thing,
if you pay attention to history or if
you read anything about the atrocities
that,
why don't we learn?
Well,
we got,
we have learned a little at what point
we're,
we're better than we were a hundred
years ago.
Better than we were 200 years ago.
But
yeah,
in the past it was like really
commonplace.
I mean,
if you,
I mean if you read anything about
socrates or anything about Plato,
like that time of the world,
like men having sex with children and
little boys and stuff was like extremely
common.
Extremely common.
What?
Yeah.
Okay.
And parts of the world.
Men having sex with boys was extremely
common for humans.
Even in like what we would consider like
classical cultural culture,
intelligent civilizations like the
ancient Romans,
the ancient Greeks that like,
it was a normal part of life.
It's really weird.
You know,
we'd want to deny that,
but there's undeniable proof that that's
a fact that it's w it was way more
common in those ancient cultures than it
is today.
Like what is that like,
how did that happen?
Like why did people allow that?
Like why did that take place?
I don't know.
I think there's,
you freaking out over there,
take some dads need to step up and beat
some ass.
Okay.
In 2005 the core DDI cuss,
say tion Frances highest criminal court
stipulated that coercion is presumed for
children at a very young age and quotes.
That's an outrageously blurry
formulation.
That in practice has largely been
applied to children under six what?
This leaves children above sex above six
years old,
six potentially considered not raped
when violence cannot be established.
It also allows the state of paralyzed
shock experienced by many victims and
all the more so children.
Okay.
To equal consent.
That's terrifying.
That is ruth,
this vikings,
barbarians,
barbarians.
And is it?
This is,
this is ancient European barbarian law
that's in place for thousands of years
and they,
they never caught up.
They never refixed it.
You've got to fix that.
This is crazy.
You have the internet fix that.
That's crazy.
You could have sex with someone under
fucking nine or six or whatever the fuck
it was.
That's nuts.
Yeah.
That's,
this isn't,
this isn't 16
two this is 2018 this is not the time
for that.
That it's amazing that this still
exists.
That's amazing.
In a,
in a European civilized,
it like really exalted culture like
France and people love the France.
It's weird.
They fight so passionately about some
things,
but then they have something so stupid.
I think they're,
they're just freer and a lot of ways,
which is bad and good at the same time.
It's bad in that regard of taking care
of children.
I'm like pr,
like fucking with children's heads
sexually,
whether you're just dooming them to this
life of weirdness.
Uh,
and you're making it legal so there's no
legal recourse.
Some guy I've got fucked by some old
dude when he was six.
That's crazy.
And that's real.
Luckily I don't know anyone that,
no,
I don't.
He like told me about that.
I'm sure it's happening now.
If that's the law,
how can,
how the fuck is that?
The law?
How's that?
The law.
Hi.
I'm no idea.
Was good to me.
Write it down.
We started this podcast literally in
haunted houses and
I've come full circle to a problem.
It's a problem.
And also the gift it,
it is,
it's both things are,
um,
our guide.
When Andy and I went to France,
he was an all tell me about that story
because that's an amazing story.
It wasn't guys went to the French Alps,
uh,
on this bow hunting,
unsuccessful bow hunting trip for tar
and just even though it was on,
it was fucking awesome.
It was success without necessarily a
harvest.
So well is a beautiful experience
problem.
Right.
It was awesome.
Um,
we actually went there and I think a
kill cliff has a dock,
a little short film on it.
Yeah.
Called,
I forget,
I think it's called high ground,
but andy and I,
andy got into bow hunting because of
you,
um,
you spur an interest to shooting a bow
and then actually you texted me one time
and said,
hey,
is it cool if I give you a friend of
mine's number to,
I want them to learn archery a little
bit better?
And so I said,
yeah,
of course.
And actually you and I had met Andy and
Vegas even though we don't totally
remember most of it.
Um,
so I said,
yeah,
of course.
And then Annie and I become,
became friends and then we went to
France.
And then uh,
we went on this epic hard,
hard high altitude hunt.
I was actually introduced to a andy
bumper,
front tait Fletcher.
Tait Fletcher knows him from the
crossfit world because Andy was a,
he was in somehow or another responsible
for something in the crosswalk.
Some something important in the crossfit
world,
some sort of a liaison.
Something I [inaudible] was there.
I don't really know cause I haven't
asked him about that part but I know
that he has background in it.
I think he was there kind of towards the
beginning of it.
I didn't know that's how tate yeah,
that's how I met Andy.
I met Andy through tape cause that's
crazy.
Take knew him cause tate's big in the
crossfit world.
I saw sweet [inaudible] actually was
following me on a post that I had made
and I was like this is such a small
world.
He's a great dude.
It really is.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
It really is.
He's the caveman coffee guy.
He's one of the owners of Casey.
Keith Jardeen.
Yeah.
Tate.
Just so you know,
Lacey Mackie,
all of those are for the or Mexico or
four nitrogens deadly for a normal sized
person.
Luckier goddamn giant.
You'd be dead.
Why?
You wouldn't be able to shut the fuck up
if you were like,
uh,
you know Duncan trussell size to be
bouncing off the walls right now.
How big is Dunkin Buck?
50.
Maybe.
What?
He's about a buck 55.
The guests.
Seriously?
Yeah.
He looks bigger than that now.
He's um,
maybe an inch taller than me.
I think he's five,
nine and I think he's more slender.
Wow.
You know,
cameras powerful.
Do you ever look at people and go,
how much does that guy way can I carry
him?
How far can I count on you?
Do you think that when you saw me,
I said this fucking dude,
if he blacks out,
we better have an ambulance.
Like get up to him.
I'm not carrying this big ass.
You would if it meant something I do.
It's a real,
what's the heaviest load you've ever
carried on your back?
Like when you,
if you've been like packing out an
animal,
if you had a gas,
definitely moose
have a whole quarter.
I think I had a quarter ahead.
Ooh.
How much does that,
I don't know.
You have to have someone help you get it
on.
Get it up there to where you can get
wait,
you know,
get that weight over the top of your
legs due to Moose quarter is fucking
heavy.
Yup.
I shot a young Moose.
It was not a very big Morris who was a
fork fork.
Hud Moose.
Um,
yeah,
it was a young,
a young men,
um,
in British Columbia with a,
a powerful Ben O'brian and my coffee
guys.
We're just,
we're right where I bear hunt.
Yeah.
That's why when I met Ben Manel.
Well,
right,
exactly.
Which is right south of where I,
where I was.
We had to take a picture of me carrying
that quarter on my shoulders.
Magazine.
Yeah.
Heavy.
I didn't have to walk with it though.
I just had to carry it.
Like how long did you have to carry a
moose shoulder on your,
on your back?
How far when he far,
how far did you pack it out?
Three,
400 yards
so that you know,
um,
remy warren ruined his body
carrying a moose out.
It took,
I think he said it took several days of
going back and forth.
There were many,
many miles in and so they go miles in,
grab like a hundred pounds of moose
meat.
A Moose,
by the way,
he might have 700 pounds of me seemed,
if you bone it out,
you have seven trips,
you know however many people you have,
you have seven individual packages of
hundred pounds of meat.
You got to get out through miles and
miles and miles of dead falls and cliffy
rocky fucking you might get cliffed out.
You might take a wrong path.
Yeah.
Hey,
hey crossfit.
Um,
what is it?
18.3 how about through 200 pounds on
your back and literally go from one
interview your town to the next.
Yeah.
When remy was telling you about it,
I was like,
that,
that sounds crazy.
But like what?
Incredible mental fortitude.
This guy had incredible mental fortitude
that he figured out how to get through
all the things that he said.
Fuck that meet.
I'll leave it back there.
Some coyotes will eat it.
Who Cares?
It's not going to waste.
I'm not going back.
It's not worth it.
He went back.
Oh yeah,
and over and over again.
I think,
I want to say it was three or four days
of packing out this Mousse.
Yeah,
I bet that's the,
that's the real western hunting that
people don't understand.
They don't understand this.
This is not elmer fudd with an orange
jacket.
The shooting at deer,
you know,
hates animals.
This is not that.
This is some crazy physical endeavor
that's highly difficult.
You need another one and another one.
I got one more drive in today.
It's two milligrams of caffeine.
You've had more honestly,
thousand milligrams caffeine.
Perfect.
I'm on par.
That right there is why hunters are
willing to,
to argue with people that slam hunting
and say that we're just killers.
Because if you had to put 800 packs of
your ribeye steak on your back and walk
it five miles home,
would you feel more passionate about it?
Well that would be ridiculous.
I was still,
it was just do eight trips.
Jesus Christ,
but it's trade a hundred pounds on your
back.
It seems excessive,
but it's true.
I mean if you have,
you have a moose even enough,
that's not even enough.
I don't,
I don't think to really complete the
cycle.
I think you'd have to be there.
You either have to be the one who pulls
the trigger or you have to be there when
it happens.
You have to see what the difference
between a living animal and dead animal.
Cause if you don't then you're,
you're formulating your entire picture
of the world based on information that
you're only getting from a video.
Right.
It's like what we were talking about,
the difference between watching porn and
having sex.
It's really similar.
The difference between understanding
this in terms of like it on video
and actually being there like,
oh this is what it looks like when a cow
dies.
This is what it looks like.
Me Hang Hangup by its ankles and gut it.
This is how I feel about this now.
I had one feeling about this before when
I was nicely insulated by all the
prides.
Got a nice white styrofoam little tray
with Saran wrap and a nice piece of rib
eye.
Oh look at that.
I'm going to get the fucking briquettes
out there and start the grill.
Woo.
You get all excited when it's not their
fault.
It's just we are.
We're even through our entire
developmental process.
We're shielded through one of the most
important parts of life.
Where does your food come from?
It should be like one of the number one
things you think of.
Where's your family?
Are they safe?
Where's your food come from?
Those are question number one and
question number two.
Right?
Well it's a lot like that with the job
too.
I mean,
and we've had people that have come to
work for us are like,
okay,
this is what working for this business
is going to be like,
and then they come and then they
realize,
whoa,
this is completely different.
Whereas I've been the same.
I've s I've worked for companies that
I've really,
really liked and I go there and then I
realize,
holy cow,
this is a whole different thing.
Yeah.
Versus what it really,
really is.
So it gets tough.
I mean,
you know,
it's hard to,
and that's why he can't really judge
anyone because unless you've been in
those shoes,
it's not really fair to build an
assessment
easy.
Now
smart first one is my first bro.
Relax.
No,
you're absolutely right.
I mean it's nothing wrong with letting
someone know that doing something wrong
that's negatively affecting others.
Yup.
That's,
that's,
that's a good thing.
But there's a,
there's a bigger issue that's like did
when people are like constantly going
after other people and attacking and the
most vicious way,
most likely it's because they're trying
to divert attention from,
from how they are or,
or that,
that it could come back at them.
You know,
this is like a weird dance that people
do with liking and disliking other
people.
It's sign always healthy.
You know,
and I've,
I've been studying this for the longest
time and I still don't understand it
totally.
I have my vague assessments of how it
all sort of falling into place,
but I don't know totally how it's
working,
but I know that's the people that are
the most pleasant to be around are the
people that are both the most friendly,
the most understanding,
the most objective in the,
the most just just loving,
just nice people,
you know,
and the,
the friends that we all have that we
know that are like that this is,
this is the fun people to be around.
You know,
you're going to have a good time.
Yep.
Every time I see you,
I know I'm going to have a good time.
We never have a bad time.
We have fun times.
Oh yeah,
we definitely do.
Well,
isn't that a nice thing?
Like how come that can't be replicated
everywhere?
I wish it could.
I totally wish it could.
I feel like,
I feel like people that haven't
experienced hardship don't appreciate
the good times as much.
And I feel like for me anyway,
the fact that I've experienced times
where I've really struggled and I've had
to either up my game or co or decided to
quit,
which,
you know,
that's your choices either either you
step up and you work hard enough to
where you achieve it and then at that
point you really,
really appreciate it.
Um,
which is something that I experienced
when you talk to me about kettle bells.
I thought,
okay,
well I'm not good at this,
so either I'm not going to be able to
relate to joe or I'm gonna learn to do
it right.
And I ended up going down to Austin
because,
um,
I wanted to experience it a little bit
more to where I can appreciate,
okay,
if Joe's doing a windmill with a
fricking big foot,
what is this?
What is this real like?
It looks easy when I watched a youtube
video,
but then when I grab a fricking chimp
and do it and,
uh,
I'm struggling to do it without having
my shoulder hit me in the side of the
face.
And then I'm thinking,
okay,
Joe's doing this now with a big foot.
I think it's like 90 90 I don't know.
Somewhere in the night.
Let's just say it's a 90 pound 90 pound
kettle bell.
You begin to realize
started out with the 35 pound one.
I struggled with it and then
it's also I'm,
I've been doing flexibility exercises
since I was a kid,
so when males not as difficult for me is
a lot of other people.
It was actually pretty easy for me to
pick up because my body's used to
whipping like everything's kicking.
Right.
All that kicking and shit kicking is a
lot of is with your hips,
a lot of is with your waist and your
hips.
When you learn how to like really throw
power and things,
that's where it all comes from.
So the windmill,
it's like a natural movement of that.
Like those muscles were already
conditioned and strengthened.
I feel like I'm adding and totally
inadequate.
When I looked at you,
I t I do,
I mean I work out every day,
but
my physique,
I feel like a lot of people look at my
physique from a distance and they think,
oh,
that guy is in really good shape.
But then like I look at you and
sometimes your abdomen protrudes a
little bit and then I've been rooms or
joe takes his shirt off and he's like a
Frickin,
he's jacked.
Don't let them fool you and work out.
Yeah,
he works out.
I'm trying to fool people.
Yeah.
He has a little bit of an abdomen that
goes out further than this tax.
It's only honest with you.
I can't even believe you have that skin
because I've been in my life.
Your six pack sticks out further than
your Pec deck
versus my Pec deck.
I'm going to show you some of the shit
that I do out here.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll do a little,
uh,
working out here.
But one of the that I've really gotten
into is,
um,
there's like a circuit of a glute ham
machine that does your lower back.
And then I do these elevated setups.
And then I do compression machine or no,
no,
no.
That's,
that's the third one.
That's the,
I'm a reverse hyper.
That's the third one.
But I do this whole series of things
that I'm doing for ABS.
It's tremendous for abs and back.
And I like the sturdiness of your core
and just,
I feel like if I just do these on a
regular basis,
it makes it just a giant difference in
how my body moves and how stable I feel.
I feel like that's why you were good at
word tree is because core so solid.
I think it's a really,
really good foundation and other
foundations,
those club bells,
I'm really in those club bells.
I do all the shield cast with those
clubs.
There's something about when you do
that,
when you're controlling like a 25 pound
club,
it doesn't seem like a lot of weight.
But if you could slowly control that,
when you get a bow in your hand and
you're trying to level that bow,
it's like you're,
you have more control of your body.
You have better understanding of,
you know,
the,
all the,
the various uh,
speeds that your muscles can move at.
We could just slow it down,
slow it down.
There it is.
And I feel like the more you strengthen
those muscles,
particularly stabilizing muscles of the
shoulders with like reverse kettle
bells,
you know,
kettle upside down kettlebells where the
bottoms,
I love those.
Those are great because those are even a
lightweight,
you're just do it slow and it's well
wiggling and she is big time hammer
curls too.
So good to deltoid,
full Schulte military shoulder press
with the vertical kettle bell and then,
but don't sleep on those windmills too
cause it's the same thing.
It's all shoulder stability actually.
And flexibility.
Being able to go to the floor is a big,
big aspect.
It's huge.
And it's just,
I feel like if as long as you don't
overdo it,
I don't think there's any danger of
injuring yourself.
I think if you do it correctly,
it's actually the opposite.
I think it strengthens everything.
Strengthens the whole chain from your
arms,
your shoulders to your court,
your hips to your legs.
The whole thing gets strengthened
because everything has to move.
Yup.
I went to a on at academy,
I think last summer.
I'm,
Sharon and I were down there for,
actually,
I think it was September,
we were down there for the hurricane
harvey.
We were down there.
We raised some newer,
you're feeding people and everything
too.
Yeah.
We raised this money.
Cool.
Have you,
that was very cool.
Part of that was because of the house
fire.
I mean obviously when I was someone who
lost everything,
so I understand where that comes from.
So when the,
I was actually on a hunt with Andy up in
Alberta when the hurricane happened and
I was completely disconnected from the
news.
I got a text from Sharon that just said,
you won't believe what's happening down
in Houston.
So we ended up coming in and I looked it
up,
uh,
with Wifi while we were in town.
And then I showed Annie and I said,
man,
this is terrible what's happening in,
down in Texas.
So He's like,
I wish we could do something.
I said,
well,
I'm Gunna,
so I just,
I ended up going live and offering to
auction off my bow during a live feed
and we ended up raising,
thankfully there were three bidders.
I don't know if I can announce who they
were,
but there were three bidders that bid,
um,
about 15 grand,
I think it was,
think it was 20,
let me think.
It was about 2100 bucks or 22,000.
And then we had one person that offered
to match the other two.
So it ended up getting to be 30,000 that
we raised,
uh,
went down to Houston and then,
um,
crispy who was doing a lot of,
a lot of really cool things for getting
supplies into the Houston area.
Crispy.
The hunting boot company?
No crispy.
Uh,
that's his instagram.
I don't know.
It was a dude.
Yeah,
he's a guy.
Crispy.
I thought you meant crispy boots.
No.
Okay.
Um,
so we,
we ended up raising a bunch of money.
Got It down there.
Went down.
You saw a lot of people to man.
Yup.
I watched a lot of those,
uh,
instagram posts.
I was really very,
very cool.
Crispy and archery country,
filled a full trailer full of supplies
in Sharon and I flew down to Houston or
we'll first we flew to Austin,
then we drove to Houston and went down
to a church where we did,
where we ended up feeding a lot of
people and then delivering all the
supplies that we raised with the money
that we got from auctioning off this
bow.
Um,
which I know what it's like to lose
everything.
So I was pretty adamant about it.
That's awesome.
Um,
yeah,
it was,
it was dynamite.
Super rewarding feeling.
Um,
I don't know where I'm going with that.
Oh,
well listen,
man,
it's a good story.
It's just cool.
And I,
I remember watching it online,
I'm like,
wow,
that's bad ass.
You know?
And I know how sincere you are about
that stuff too,
you know,
I think,
um,
that's a great,
great expression,
you know,
great thing to do.
You did the same thing for Vegas.
I mean you're passionate about certain
things and you know,
we've,
we've had a lot of doors open for us
from different communities.
Texas was a big one for me because I
worked for an archery company for many
years in Texas,
was one of my states as a sales rep.
Um,
did,
that's one of the few places I'd live if
I didn't live in California because if
you pay said live,
I was an la,
I think in northern California.
I think of like San Diego.
I like San Diego,
Colorado,
Montana.
Yeah.
Once I get out of cop once to get out of
California,
then I'm my Colorado,
Montana.
I,
Texas,
Texas is in the mix baby.
Cause I like Texans,
man.
I like,
I,
there's,
there's a stereotype about the worst
texans,
but they're not the best Texans.
So you never met the best tech since the
best Texans.
Like,
Oh,
you're like some cool combination of
smart and old school.
You know,
you're a cool combination of like hip
and,
and progressive and toddler on a tiger.
And also you have guns.
You want a tiger?
He could get a dye.
Yeah.
Oh,
you remember,
did you see my bed?
Remember that bit?
You saw the little bit that I used to do
about Texas.
It's legit though.
It is legit.
Texas has more tigers in captivity than
all of the wild of the world.
Okay.
More in Texas.
And my joke was like one dude was like
going through the regulations,
like she hit,
I don't know,
you get a tiger ordered up to order it
up and then his neighbor found out,
he goes,
mom,
I didn't know you get tired.
His neighbors got to guy tires and he's
like,
man about ain't about to let this fag it
out.
Tiger me.
And he opened up tiger world.
It's fucking ridiculous joke.
That's based on a true fact that there's
more tigers in captivity in Texas than
anywhere in the world.
But Texas,
the thing is Texas of 2018 is not Texas
of even 2008 and definitely not Texas of
1,980 [inaudible] it's better and
smarter and it's a,
it's a good place to be.
Men.
Texas is a good place to be.
It's one of my favorite spots.
It is cool.
I love it there,
man.
I liked the people.
There's sort of,
it's a weird combination.
It's like a country.
It's a kind of think it is.
I think it is too.
It's a completely different
okay.
Being it,
everything about it's different,
isn't it?
True.
Well,
I always explained it on stage about
buckeys.
You're taking people that have never
been a buckeys,
which I went to the first buckeys on
that heat on when I took supplies down
to Houston for the hurricane.
Yeah.
That was my first time at a buckies and
I thought,
is this a Frickin Costco?
But with fuel,
it doesn't make any sense.
The way I describe it on stage,
I always say this is like if you were in
the middle of a full on cocaine binge,
well someone came up to you and said,
dude,
I want you to make me the ultimate gas
station.
It's a gas station with hundreds of
pumps.
Like you can't believe how many pumps
there are.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's like God damn field of pumps.
And then you go into this building and
it is a fucking warehouse filled with
pickled alligator Dick.
So different kinds of jelly beans and
chuck Norris action genes and camouflage
and Yeti coolers and smokers.
You're like,
what the fuck is this?
And it's huge.
I mean it's like a fucking God damn
football field sized room filled with
jelly beans,
different kinds of Cammo and real tree.
There's a buckeys right there.
There you can see that's a mild bucky.
Is that?
That's a plug that's on the edge of the
fucking Wyoming or some shit.
Chuck Norris.
Geez,
there's so many pumps.
It doesn't make any sense.
Look at that right there.
How many pumps is that?
One,
two,
345678910 1112 504010202122 jets into
fortunate and double.
It might be on double it.
That might be a hundred right,
and there's two on each one,
so it literally might be 200 for fucking
pumps.
Well,
that's crazy.
Why doesn't Chuck Norris Make Jeans?
Sears too.
Awesome.
He used to,
he used to,
I used to own a pair of what?
Let's see these.
I'm alive.
Any,
no,
not anymore,
but I used to put them on the lace up in
the front.
They did?
Yeah.
The laced up in the front and let you do
sidekicks.
There it is.
Bam.
It has a gusset.
Looks like Chris Irwin.
They had a gusset in the crotch area.
I like that.
The lace up to the front,
so I might be lying.
That might be a little longer in scene
there for that.
That cowboy boot kick.
Well,
back in the day they didn't understand
about barbell jeans.
They didn't have the time.
Top of fabric technology.
I do have a pretty good kick distance.
Have you ever seen mine?
I'm sure it's very long.
It is.
We'll make a video it later at the top
of a doorway.
Ooh,
look at that dress shirt.
That gentleman right there will always
have my respect.
Him and Bruce Lee or the reason why I
got into martial arts a hundred percent
watch it.
Chuck Norris movies.
When I was a kid,
one of my most proudest moments of my
life was in Chuck Norris.
Do who I was.
I ran into him at a kickboxing event in
New Jersey like way back in the day,
and it gave me this big hug.
It was one of his events that he had.
He had a world combat.
He gave me a big hug.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Chuck Norris knows who I am.
Damn right.
It couldn't have been happier.
No wonder you're unbreakable.
Soccer was beeman.
And then we'll later,
uh,
I took a picture of me and tate tate
again.
Um,
it was a,
a award show that they did for an old
school karate master and Chuck Norris
was there and a bunch of other,
uh,
old school,
American black belt karate guys,
and they're telling these awesome
oldschool karate stories.
They didn't ask me to be there and speak
a little bit and I would wouldn't,
I mean I do anything for Chuck Norris.
Like,
no bullshit.
Go corny as you want for watches.
Chuck Norris changed.
He changed my life for real.
If it wasn't for Chuck Norris movies,
who knows,
I might not ever got into martial arts.
I watched him and like lone wolf,
mcquaid and shit.
I was like,
God damn,
that might be the coolest guy that's
ever lived.
Did she laugh?
Uh,
the other night in Vegas when we were
talking about what my wife,
Sharon's name was supposed to be and
when we're coming up with fake names for
people know her,
what she was saying at Debra?
No,
but that was the fake name.
He goes the fake name.
My wife's name.
Her Dad actually wanted to name right.
Bruce Lee.
Oh,
that's right.
That was the crazy story of all time.
I forgot about that dude.
Share and vape pens.
He knew making a rude if your mood,
if you knew Sharon,
you would laugh at this.
But uh,
her dad was in a nun chucks and all
kinds of solar and wind to my wife.
When my wife was born.
They didn't know what she was going to
be.
So they had a,
he really wanted her name to be Bruce
Lee.
But if you knew Sharon,
you'd knew,
you know,
she is far from briefly.
Do we have any more Alpha brain we need?
Um,
I made a deal with my wife.
I said,
I'm not naming the kids.
I'm like,
I just have veto power.
I mean,
this is not fair.
I go,
I just,
it's like that was a good story to,
it grew in your body.
I'm like,
I'm not,
I'm not telling you what to name them.
I mean,
I will.
I will 100% be there,
but I'm saying like this,
let's not pretend this is an even
proposition like you doing that like
99.99999% of the work.
Like you just,
as long as you don't call them fucking
apple sauce or something crazy.
This is my kid pixie.
You're not going to torture them with
your wacky bullshit,
but KCC.
I just gave my suggestions,
my feelings,
but I was like,
there's no way it's fair for me to name
the kid.
You know?
Actually,
she did have some goofy ass name for
dudes and I might've had to put the
fucking stamp on.
I know how hard it is for guys.
Like a guy like John or a guy like joe
that's,
those are good names there.
Solid,
solid.
There is.
You can't file ood your fucking named
John.
You'd be like,
what are you talking about?
I had to see but like a fool.
I had a CB uh,
in junior high and I actually,
I've always loved frogs.
I know you have a frog tattoo and you're
okay.
Jamie.
Google a Pixie frog.
What's a Pixie frog?
So the real thing,
I used to have several.
I had a pixie frogs.
I like Jamie's a little controversial,
right?
I got get shit for that a little bit
because it's a girl's name was no other
fuckers.
Those motherfuckers who came first.
Hello Kelly.
Kelly's like always a back and forth.
When came first though,
it's pat was on.
So like when I was like that a kid
Saturday that Sammy Saturday night live
fricking ruin and pat shelley's and
other ones.
Shelley used to be a common name for a
gentlemen was Shelly Finkel.
Shelly Finkel.
You see one of them?
Mike Tyson is a financial managers.
Yeah.
Pixie frogs are pretty big.
Shelly Shit.
There's a bunch of shelley's,
a bunch of old Jewish men.
That was shelly's sheldon,
right at the shelter.
Yes.
Shelly Kelly.
Shelly.
I know a dude named Kelly got a fucking
tattoo on his neck.
What's up bitch?
A punch you in the face
kick isn't used anymore except for like
if someone's being a dick.
Yeah,
you're right.
Back in the day.
Here's the crazy thing about dick.
Dick was from Richard and then how was
that possible?
Jack's from John.
How has chuck from Charles?
I looked that one up.
These are all like Jack thing.
It's like the Irish.
I think they would just learn how to
talk fucking ape.
Well,
my dad's middle name is definitely
straight on a page.
My Dad's middle name is deloitte.
Deloitte deal.
Why like exactly like homer Simpson.
No,
homeless him.
Look at that.
Oh my God.
My tank.
What's happening to the show?
Dude?
I used to have to grow in life.
No,
this is a Pixie frog,
but you're just not just pixie frog and
fixie frog eating a fucking rat with
it's poking out the camera.
I would have to buy mice to feed my,
to pete feed my pixie frog because he
ate mice to look at the size of that.
Go back to that one.
Please look at the size of its body with
the full mouse in his body.
He just expands like a water balloon.
That's crazy.
That's such a crazy,
she's like frogs.
And I thought they were really cool.
Especially pixie frogs.
They were super aggressive.
They would eat something up to their
size.
Holy Shit.
Like you could put a mouse in their cage
the same size as them and they would
tackle it crick and smoke it.
I had them have you never seen him?
It's a little tiny monster,
right?
So my,
yeah.
Oh my God.
We go all the way up Joe.
Take that picture and send it to me.
Take a picture of that.
Sends me,
there might be the greatest picture I've
ever seen in my life.
Save image.
So,
so my shit out of me with that
handle Pixie.
And I didn't know that a Pixie wasn't
cool until someone else like address me
on it.
But I always saw the rock.
It's like a trick.
It's like the most demonic ruthless
thing.
How many animals eat an animal their
size?
I Dunno.
That sucker did not a whole lot.
That sucker did.
Mine was the size of a dinner plate.
Unless that kid is a pixie himself.
No,
we're looking at as a young man,
my lips like was this big.
That little fella looks like he's about
seven years old.
This is an African bull frog.
What it is,
it's a Pixie.
This is how big my frog was.
We're holding John Dudley's holding us a
typical ice tray that you would get in a
hotel room.
I would call it ice buckets rather
rabbit.
Oh my God.
Look at the size of that rabbit might be
a small girl.
No,
it was a big rabbit.
I could tell by his feet.
Go to it doesn't look right.
It took a second look at them all.
Oh yeah.
That's another one.
Eating a rat to their monsters.
I had a lot of videos in mine.
Just smoke in mice.
That's crazy to think that it can
literally eat something at the same
time.
They were so it was a full fucking
python.
They found in Florida,
in the everglades,
that Ada deer,
110% I think I saw that.
What have you,
assholes done?
You fucking Leonard skinner,
loving muscle car driving dip shits keep
a pythons and a fucking terrarium in
your bedroom with Motley crue posters on
the wall and you'd do acid.
Decided that that that they go in your
yard.
Now they're eating deer that are 111
pounds.
They're fucking huge man.
Leave that day.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God,
it's so big.
This thing is so big.
This guy's holding onto it is,
is that a biologist that's got it?
He's holding on to the mouth and the
head controlling the body and inside of
it is this enormous lump that is
apparently a deer that's bigger than
it's a whole body in terms of his body
weight.
Do you ever see them one more one died
because it was trying to eat an
alligator.
He received that one.
I think so dude.
This is how gangster pythons are.
They are a gangster,
alligators.
Anything that can unlock its jaw is
pretty gangster dude.
They fuck with alligators.
They look at an alligator and they go,
I'm going to just try to eat you.
I saw,
I actually went to a comedy skit at
Riviera memory where you're talking
about that.
Look at this thing,
dude,
I don't interrupt a little bit,
but go,
go to the upper left upper left corner.
You get the best example.
This is what happened.
It died because the alligator blew out
the side of his asshole.
What?
I try to eat this thing,
I mean,
this literally happened.
It literally swallowed up this fucking
hole alligator face first,
and the alligator backed it's way out of
its asshole and they both died in the
everglades.
But there's this fucking snake is so
big,
it's trying to eat an alligator that's
bigger than it.
Yeah.
It doesn't care.
These
crazy fucks have let these things loose
in the United States of America.
It's simple math that,
uh,
that comic that we saw at Riviera I saw
in the late nineties,
which I think you were there at that
time.
We're talking about,
which is kind of crazy.
Uh,
but he,
he has going on here.
Jamie,
cutting a person out of a snake.
Oh,
wonderful.
Good Times.
Timing
is this some place,
John,
the lead and fucking narrowly escaped my
train set on my train is dead.
Oh my God.
It is a fucking person coming out of
this is what you need to learn folks.
Just because you watch nature doesn't
mean do you know nature.
Just like if you watch porn,
you're not getting laid.
It's the same thing.
If you take anything from this podcast,
take that nature is like where you go,
where you go.
We were talking about BC and you,
you go bear hunting.
Tell the people how crazy it is up
there.
You're in the forest filled with
monsters.
Oh yeah.
Well they don't,
uh,
they don't watch the news.
It's all about they can't,
can I eat you?
Yeah.
Well,
pretty much like this.
My mouth is this big.
You're this big.
I think you can fit in it.
Yeah.
That's as simple as it gets that comic
at revere that time.
Who Was it?
Do we,
I don't
know.
I wish I knew because it was actually a
good rules are a really good bid.
He said.
Yeah,
he,
he pretty much talked about uh,
the fact that he,
you know,
he's so sick of people getting uh,
complaining about how fast they get
because he said,
you know,
literally it's simple math people.
Your mouth is this big.
Your butt holes this big.
At some point there's a bottleneck.
And he just said,
he said between your mouth and you're in
your asshole.
It wasn't,
it wasn't don my rare,
well I don't know.
It was so long ago.
I mean it was 20 years ago at most.
That sounds like something.
Dot Marrero.
Say he just said,
listen,
it's simple math.
That's your mouth.
Is this big butt holes this big?
Yeah.
Why are you complaining about being fat?
Well,
that's the real concept behind that.
Um,
16 hour fasting.
You know,
Eddie Bravo in your mouth.
I was doing 14 for a while,
but Eddie said that it's 16 is really
where all the benefits happen.
So all right,
I'll give it a try.
So I tried 16 and a I see it.
There's definitely something to it.
There's more alertness.
Um,
I processed food better.
I think giving your body a smaller
window to process food is really wise.
I think it also,
it aids you because it gives you
discipline.
Just even just a little discipline.
It's just a baby baby amount of
discipline.
But it's a no,
it's a lot.
It's not,
it's not really to me and you,
it's not,
but just some people that is seriously,
but it's all relative.
But I'm just being honest with them.
If they just,
they need to get past that.
It's not really a lot,
but the benefits of it,
like how you feel when you finally have
your first meal.
When you cross over the line,
like you feel better and your body works
better and you have more energy.
That's a fact I have for you.
Absorb it faster.
You and I both are big.
Fasters I th I mean I fast.
Um,
I normally eat last maybe about seven
o'clock at night and then I normally
eating in about 10 or so in the morning.
So I mean it's,
it's quite a bit of time.
And when I eat,
I legitimately feel like I can feel my
body absorbing everything that I'm
consuming.
Right.
Like it's processed.
Everything else.
That's how it's supposed to be.
I mean that's really what fat is all
about,
right?
Fat Is all about you just keep
stockpiling.
Even though your body hasn't processed
is like,
I don't even want to put,
I'll put it over here and your body's
like stacking up fat over your body
instead of utilizing it for fuel.
You're just not burning off enough
calories.
Yup.
You know that is,
that's what this whole fasting thing
sort of normalize this for me at least.
It just gives you this opportunity where
your body says,
let's just digest everything we got
here.
Let's just do this,
and then when there's dude wakes up in
the morning,
would it be burning fats is the way to
go and then you feel good.
You have more energy.
Body is using ketones,
especially if you're like someone like
myself that I'm not eating a lot of
bread.
If I eat bread once every two or three
weeks,
it's a big deal for the pasta.
Once every two or three weeks,
it's a big deal.
Do you feel like dog shit when you do?
No.
No,
but I don't go crazy.
I don't go crazy if I don't go crazy.
I don't feel bad.
But if I do go crazy,
if I eat like a big piece of chocolate
cake and some ice cream,
I feel it way more now.
Way more now.
I think you're more in tune if you're,
if you're conscious about it,
I think you have a better understanding
of what it actually does to you.
That's a problem with people that are in
the lifestyle of doing every single day
is they don't really realize what it's
doing to them.
I think there's that.
But I think there's also obviously a
tolerance that you develop.
Just like people develop a tolerance for
alcohol.
People develop a tolerance for weed.
People definitely I think develop a
tolerance for sugar.
And when I don't have it,
then I feel the full brunt of sugar.
And it's like I remember,
um,
I took my family to get cheeseburgers
and milkshakes and I had a big ass
fucking vanilla milkshake and it was so
good.
Oh my God,
I was drinking this big ass like 20
ounce vanilla milkshake and I was eating
this cheeseburger and I hit the wall so
hard after it was over I had a sit down
like a bike.
What kind of bitch in mind that I'm,
I'm getting taken out.
I get like hamstring buy a cheeseburger
and a milkshake,
but it was just clearly that I've been
eating clean for so long.
My body had no idea what to do with that
giant dump of sugar.
How much sugar do you think is in 20
ounces or 18 and I don't know how much
it was like one of those,
you know those Sunday drink things that
give you a where it's a big ass.
Oh God.
Glass fill.
Which ice cream milkshake today I was in
the airport in De Moines and I got a
coffee hundred grams.
Oh my God.
20 ounce chocolate shake.
Nutrition information.
How many tablespoons is that?
100.
How many tablespoons is a hundred oh my
god,
it's so crazy.
It was in de Moines airport this
morning.
I got a coffee and a guy behind me
getting a coffee.
He was like,
I think he was a baggage handler for one
of the airlines.
I literally came up and I poured nothing
but half and half in my coffee.
I'm a big,
I actually feel like I thrive off fat
now,
right,
because that's what my body wants.
He unscrewed the top of the jar of meth?
No.
Yeah,
pretty much.
He unscrewed the top off the sugar and
he started,
I was actually like,
God,
dude,
can you do that again so I can video
this?
He unscrewed the top off the sugar and
started pouring his coffee and he poured
and I was like,
oh my God,
is that a lot?
And then he kept going and kept going
and kept going and then he tipped the
thing down,
put the top back on the sugar and then
poured in fricking creamer and I was,
I was sitting there like,
dude,
that is,
it's rich.
It's literally like two or three times
what you're saying and the problem
is this guy that was half my size needed
that to feel like he could get the day
going or it's a big,
that's a big problem.
His job so bad.
They just wanted to go into a diabetic
coma in the middle of the fucking middle
of the work floor.
He's just like,
look,
fuck this insulin.
I'm just eating about a half a pound of
sugar.
Let's do this.
Okay.
I love it.
It's got myself wet.
What's that?
No,
it's okay.
It's just my pants.
It's just this.
Nothing about jeans.
My barbell jeans are wet.
Look,
embarrassment.
Listen,
this is for your own good ladies and
gentlemen.
It's for comedy.
It is.
We're okay though.
No computer.
No.
How many tablespoons of sugars in a
hundred grants.
When I think of a hundred grams,
I'm thinking like a baseball of sugar.
That's what I think.
It's a lot.
A major league baseball of sugar.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
for sure.
Is that legit?
Can I see like a physical representation
of 100 grams of sugar?
One tablespoon equals 12 grams.
That's eight.
Eight and a half.
That's so crazy.
What does that look like?
Quite a baseball.
It's a baseball because in baseball,
Huh?
Eight and a half.
Eight and a half is bigger than a golf
ball.
That's,
I'm just being conservative.
How many golf balls?
One Kiwi.
Two.
Three.
I bet it's two golf balls,
Jamie.
Whoa,
that's a lot.
If you got damn fault nor did that,
you'd be on cloud.
Nine seconds.
Look at that corridor just to get
proportion.
That's crazy.
Holy Nuggets.
That's all are you fucking know?
No wonder why it hits a wall.
Cups.
Paris.
There's a hundred grams right here.
I think it's comparing a hundred grams.
Two Cups.
Oh,
there's two gaps.
So it's one cup,
one cup the size of the hundred grams.
That's nuts.
That's so much sugar.
And that's what's in a milkshake.
I got to go to the doctor 10 years ago,
but I still have to go to the doctor
today because of it.
Um,
let's wrap this up.
I going to pee again.
It's already four o'clock.
Let's shoot some arrows.
If you're interested in
a high level archery instruction and
information,
knock on podcasts.
You can go to a itunes.
You get it on Google play.
It's on.
Is it on Google?
Play stitcher,
stitcher.
Um,
knock on TV on instagram.
Knock on archery.com it's the best.
What's the instagram though?
Knock on TV.
Instagram.
A twitter as well.
I Dunno,
I don't tweet much.
He doesn't tweet marriage.
Just check them out on instagram.
We're done,
ladies and gentlemen.
We did about a fuck fucking 15 hour
podcasts.
How long was that for hours.
That's my,
that's enough.
You've
heard enough.
We loved you.
Bladders may love these people.
Love these people.
John Dudley,
tell bicep.
Tell these people you love them.
I love you.
Freaks.
Bye.
Awesome.